identifying information online by personally releasing personally
identifying information by releasing personally identifying I'm
trying to answer information online that you are opening yourself
up to doxing that is not supposed to like okay you're not trying
to answer your question I'm trying to answer your question
what you are saying Aiden is that basically there is no definition
of doxing there is no definition of doxing that will apply to
me you are supposed to stay away from me
acceptable person in the chat alone You go. You go. >> I
haven't recently. >> I'm never going to do this again,
by the way. This is the only
talk to Ladies. Ladies, to make this >> something There's
something about this kind of content that just like goes so >> Make
a make. Let's just do one at a
>> Wait, there's another piece of content I've never gotten
to that I kind of want to and I think would be perfect for this
time of night. I think it'd be high energy. I think it'd be just
right.
I've not followed up on this at all, but there's the Duckbringer
call in to Aiden from like a week ago. >> No mods. >> Five
five days ago. I've heard this is
I've heard this is very, very good. Oh, apparently he was going
over the Willy Mac stuff in uh from Chud's Discord as well. So,
I kind of want to watch this. This is just um this is somebody
who hangs out in the pawns scum community, the the the
what do you call it? the Whiz Walker, Wizard Walker and Smug
Bug community and a little bit in the lonerbox community. And
this this person I think gets like um this person kind of gets
unhinged with Aiden. I don't know exactly why to be to be honest
with you. I know it's something to do with like I know Ieko eventually
joins. It's like some comments from Ieko and Oh, because they're
dating Resi now, right? It must be the resi IO. Yes. Yes. Yes.
Yes. Yes. >> Around to delete this. the server has never
had a had a a policy where they've allowed doxing. It's clear
Destiny's found this after the fact. And if that's true, what
evidence did you have that led to your initial claim
that this community was Kiwi Farms adjacent hosting doc? Because
pri Oh, Aiden's just running through. Yeah, I don't know if you
realize this, Aiden. Destiny's just maliciously lying. He like
he doesn't even think he has evidence. He doesn't think he needs
evidence. He's just maliciously lying, that's all. Um, yes, he's
just that Aiden's fundamentally misunderstood. Aiden still thinks
Destiny might be like a useful or useful person to politics or
like a some some way a redeemable person. He's not. He's a totally
irredeemable malicious loser. So, >> prior to this, I don't
think there's been a single example of that occurring. But because
>> the one where she starts screeching, I've been told
>> Spencer H thought this was a [__] genius
idea. Okay. Absolutely total genius we're dealing with here.
Now, if I was to debate Destiny on the subject, I can't just
say who is spicy chat doxed. Okay, with Yeah, it doesn't matter.
The line Oh, you're Aiden. The line is never who is this chat
doxed. Individual actors can do whatever they want. You could
go Aiden Aiden right now. Aiden underground. You could go to
Destiny's DG chat and post
cheesy pizza. Okay, that doesn't mean people post it there prominently.
That doesn't mean it's a community where that stuff gets posted.
That doesn't mean it's a community where they want that stuff
posted, right? How they respond to that if they see it and or
it's reported is what makes the rules is what makes the like
the essence of that community, right?
So essentially, did Chud's Discord do they broadly allow this
or they like, "Oh, it's cool." You never say, "Oh, well, it's
never happened because then they could just do gay op, right?
They just they just actually go and do it." You never say that's
the line, which is the whole point of the Keles manifesto. Destiny
or sorry, Aiden's missed out on some some Destiny lore apparently
being in college. Okay. The whole point of the Kevl manifesto
is just because you have like one bad actor, I can punish that
person. Just report them to me. Doesn't mean it's the the core
character of my community.
>> Destiny can now do is be like, "Look, this was in chat
for days and never got deleted. It's clear the moderators uh
allow it or okay with it." And I said, >> "Wait, I don't
think it stayed in chat for days. I thought this got deleted
from Chud's Discord like almost immediately." Like I thought
Spencer posted it and deleted it within like less than an hour
or something. Like somebody was like, "Dude, are you?" And he
was like, "Oh." And deleted it. No. What I will say is, well,
I'll say exactly what I just said about one mod being on vacation,
the other being asleep, uh, the other being a [__]
And he'll his response be like, "Yeah, sure. We all, everyone
believes that, man. Everyone believe." And then like amongst
his crowd and like the Ethan people and like your like Willys
and Dioras that will be an own on him cuz nobody that will be
an own on his part. That'll be an o the debate will literally
come down to intent. Okay, that's what the debate will come down
to. This is moronic and the mods that did not remove this and
b Oh, Aiden is totally soying, isn't he? Aiden is is Aiden not
totally incorrect on this? I actually went in a little too early.
I think is I feel like Aiden might be totally wrong on this.
Am I >> And this guy prior to Destiny calling it out are
incompetent and moronic. And I called out how incompetent.
>> I thought they like he basically was like, "Oh, my bad.
Deleted, right? I'll delete in a sec or something." Oh, this
is stupid though that he posted and says, "I'll delete in a sec."
Yeah, he deserve I think he got like a weekl long timeout or
something for doing this. I think they permit him after. It was
like it was there for a couple seconds then he did delete it
and somebody got a screenshot of it. So I think they gave him
a weak timeout. It depend. It does depend like how long you're
going to time out somebody for depending on like what they intend.
I would probably perma this person. I feel like I would perma
this person. Sometimes somebody can like sort of mistakenly do
some [__] like this. This isn't a mistake. You can
permit this personic they are. And like 10 minutes later they
came in to to try to argue with me and it was just like
>> It was literally whining like um we don't get paid for
this. I was sleeping. Um, and it was like, "Dude, I got over
this 10 minutes ago. Um, why you still whining about this?" Uh,
your incompetence is not my problem. >> Yeah, you can't
you can't mods will not catch everything in any of these cases.
It has to be reported. That's the line that's the line for forethought.
That's the line for that Destiny defended. That's the line Destiny
defended during the CEO's manifesto. That's the line that is
most defensible. Unfortunately, basically, no mods in these communities
get paid. And realistically, they can't have 100% coverage, right?
It just is impossible. So, it's like the line is report to me
when people are like way out of line and I will time them out
or I will ban them where appropriate. >> Duckbringer is
in the chat. What is Duckbringer saying? What insight is Duckbringer
providing?
They call her sane Duckbringer to highlight how sane and not
real she is. >> Uh, I don't know why I said unfortunately.
I say that sometimes.
I say unfortunately sometimes in far worse situations. Unfortunately
for these guys, they got banned for Yeah, I just I
>> not gonna lie, Chud can undermod spicy chat and use
this as an excuse.
As long as What is that? What are you saying? Why are you giving
Destiny info? You could easily argue that it's in the public
interest. No, cuz I'm not arguing from a position of bad faith.
I'm arguing from a position of principles and this isn't okay.
It is not in the public interest to know this. Not at all. This
would not be justified under
under what I consider doc >> what was the photo? I think
this is a Willy Mack photo or something. I think it's a photo
of Willie Mack or some >> boxing and my standards for it.
This would not be justified. >> Do you think mods should
be paid? No. >> But also Duckbringer. What are you saying
here? I don't know what you're trying to say. >> Bring
Duckbrer in. >> Am I like missing something? But point
being mod's really salty. I called >> Well, hold on. Spicy
chat isn't even that spicy. It doesn't need constant moderation.
I think the the issue used to be that like people would try to
like push the envelope in spicy and then I think they got like
a warning from Discord for like yeah like you guys are you guys
are kind of going off and I think they're just like here are
the lines I they mod quite aggressively there and they don't
mod in a way where it's like oh you get banned. You get modded
in a way where sorry you get like a timeout. you in a way it's
like hey if you up you're just never coming back unless we know
you like bye we don't need here if you can't read the rules and
follow them you're just gone permanently so it leads to people
being pretty stringent about the rules pretty strict about it
>> for weeks whatever okay nothing to stylo was the one
that was the most mad about this and I gave this guy an out I
literally said he was sleeping I gave this guy out and he still
got about it sad stuff man they call him sensitive
dude I I hope Aiden understands that like you might not have
mods in his discord and people go to like an inactive channel,
post something up and then what? >> I agree with you mostly.
>> And then what? >> Well, thank you for your agreement.
>> nobody proved that out by the way. We're not interested
in being correct on this. I'm just saying it's about what happens
when it's reported. >> Duckbringer is in call-ins. >> That
does happen. Loki Coco. Yes. >> Duckbringer, what's up?
>> Hey, you're ranting about spicy. You're ranting about
uh spicy chat right now. >> I guess. >> Stylo in
particular. Yeah, Stylo, for example, the other day um banned
me for apparently instigating what he calls his fantasy like
basic.
>> But does anybody have the logs that Duckbringer got
banned for? I need them now. Stat, can anybody DM me with the
logs? Can anybody put them in stream chat? Can anybody put them
in content, please? Stream chat in the Discord. Uh I have to
see what style actually bad. I don't understand why you're like
I don't understand why you're attributing like a level of seriousness
to the moderation of spicy chat to begin with because even if
there's active doxing going on unless it's enough to where the
server moderators are worried the server is going to get deleted,
they're not really going to act on it. They don't really
>> what this is just completely incorrect. This is completely
fantastical that she's saying this. Unfortunately, Spicy has
been under the lens that like my Discord is currently under for
a long time with like the the DJers who are looking to report
them, right? They Chud never calls it out because Chud doesn't
want to fight with that community at all. I don't really have
a choice. But it like it is like those people. It is I mean also
like jilted people, right? Who will go and try to report. So
they've been like super strict on like this for a long time.
>> Well, they they act on like for example, they have like
preconceived standards with the chat. They do moderate like discussion
of Destiny's kid, right? Nobody's going to get the server is
not going to get banned for merely discussing Destiny's kid,
but it's not a good look and it's probably not something we should
entertain. So, they they delete it and don't allow it. It's a
rule in the chat, right? So, so if they were if they would do
something like that, I don't know why them deleting docs would
be that like crazy of an assumption, they would go do that, >> No,
it's just it's inconsistent as what I'm saying is the the inconsistency
the inconsistency is like the the point there, right? Like they
they don't they want to have the excuse of saying, "Well, we
don't really heavily moderate spicy chat, so if there's a thing
going on, whatever. If there's doxing going on, um, if it's against
somebody they dislike, they >> No, no, doxing has always
been against the rules in spicy chat. Everybody knows this because
what happened was there was a whole controversy with Lav back
in the day where they had to make sure that this was like a strict
strict strict policy. Like no, no, no, no, no. Like literally
not even remotely. Not even like hinting at, not even like possibly
amplifying no post to Kiwi Farm, nothing like this, right? They've
already gone through all of this. I know for a fact they've gone
through all of this and I know their policies have changed to
be like what they are now where it's like no no zero tolerance.
>> They will let it go. If there's harassment going on,
if there's any toos violations going on in spicy chat against
somebody they dislike, they will actively not moderate it. So
that's just kind of like >> I I have no evidence for that
besides this, but they're not even saying it was because it was
someone they didn't like. They're saying I verifies by the way
Bug was actually on vacation and Stylo does not mod at night
cuz he is in the US. Uh, and Crow does stay in general with an
active with with as active as of a community as Chud has, he
should be able to have mods for all time of day. He should know
that if auto mod
is basically like this is intentional. The lack of moderation
in spicy chat is intentional. The lack of the lack of moderation
is not a problem. Lack of moderation is kind of like you're reacting
to it like in a way they >> Well, no. No. Okay. No, because
this was not Just be clear, this docs in Spicy and the reaction
from Destiny was not intentional. They would they literally banned
Spencer as soon as Destiny called this out because they know
it's a bad look. They actively avoid creating a bad look by like
shutting down things like discussion of Destiny's kid. Now the
under moderation, I can attribute that to to Chud not wanting
to trust Rand. Okay, Chud is like very suspicious of and there
was never a need for more moderation cuz General is dead and
Spicy has like for the most part been able to abide by toos.
So the need for additional mods has just not arisen where the
idea would like be some like immediate necessity. at this point
after this I think it should be a consideration and they should
absolutely do it but and that's what I was arguing in chat they
need more mods but I don't think it's like >> well that's
what I'm saying the lack of moderation is intentional so yeah
you are going to have things like this slip through the crack
>> low mod count is not a problem it's >> obviously
this is a bad look for spicy >> negligence I'd say it's
negligence I think it's negligence >> yeah it's intentional
negligence is what I'm saying like yeah it's it's by design I
don't think they're going to add more mods just the same way
they don't want to add more mods because basically if you if
you had a mod that was sitting in spicy chat and their intention
was to go over everything that was technically a toos violation
like doxing, right? Um there would be a whole lot more moderation
on spicy chat. It would not be the same thing which just >> Okay,
so there should be way more evidence than this. The is duckbrer
talking about like she she just said oh actually people get doxed
at spicy chat all the time and Destiny has one picture from like
the day before this post. >> You know what negligence is,
right?
>> How can it be intent? I mean when you say like intentional
negligence I guess like the usage of the word intentional using
it >> I mean Aiden does Aiden not understand that there
is a will a concept called willful negligence willful ignorance
willful negligence
like you can you can say we're going to understaff something
until it's uh I guess what would you call it gross negligence
as well you're going to understaff like a project until it fails
there are things like this >> wrong intentional intentional
intentionally looking the other way you >> okay but that's
the characterization that I disagree The mod saw this. >> Yeah,
you can't intentionally look the other way. You can't intentionally
allow doxing, then you just allow doxing. >> They probably
would have >> Sorry. You can't intentionally allow doxing
and then have it be intentional >> Deleted it, right? Because
they do the same for other cases that that snake could use to
weaponize against them. I.e. discussion of his kid. So, I don't
know why this wouldn't apply. >> I guess when you're saying
discussions of his kid, are those things being moderated during
times where mods are active or not? Cuz what I'm saying is like
obviously like stuff with kids is a lot more egregious than stuff
with when it comes to
>> a lot more laws, a lot more legal >> There's no
laws. There's no lies that would protect from this. >> It's
even the discussion of like, hey, Destiny's kid just made an
insane post on Twitter. I think doxing is going to look way worse
than that. >> Um, certainly, but both >> willful
negligence is not just intentional bad action. It is it's like
a it's like a degree removed, right? Willful negligence is not
like just not doing the thing. That's negl that's like that's
literally it's not negligence. That's literally just bad intention,
bad action, right? It's It's setting up the circumstances that
will allow the bad thing to happen. I would say it's like a degree
removed. It feels like it's a degree removed >> are bad.
I agree. Like I agree. >> Like noticing that um Oh, what
would you call it? Like not doing maintenance on on trains for
a long period of time and getting one of them to run off the
road or something? No. No. >> So, wait, you're saying got
to be a better example. >> Doxing is going to look worse
than like outing the activity of a kid on >> You're not
You're not outing it. Okay. His activity is already being discussed.
He's like making pro genocide tweets. They just don't want to
entertain combos about it in their chat, right? I don't think
there's anything morally wrong with discussing uh what
>> do you think has to do with the level of toos enforcement?
Like do you think it has to do with the level of um I don't know
like what is is going to actually come down on the server broadly
like what they're willing to mod about? Cuz I think they're they're
basically as loose as possible and I think that's actually a
good policy. >> Well well they're loose to the extent of
like the culture remains intact. They encourage self moderation
which is something I'm trying to do on my server but there are
certain things they just do not allow. doxing being one of them.
If you dox somebody and the mods see that, they will absolutely
not allow it. Chud would certainly never be willing to turn a
blind eye to that because he knows that it could be like weaponized
against them. But from Chud's perspective, it's never really
been an issue that he's had to like come across up to this point
with only his three moderators. If something is working for you
at the moment, um there's no real reason to change it. And but
and then >> I highly doubt I highly doubt I have I've had
my picture and my like age and whatever. Like I guess it also
has to do with who's going to actually um report to the mods,
right? >> Okay. So you have a personal gripe.
I I do think it's very funny
that in general
Destiny amplified this docs to like a thousand times more people
than Spencer did. And and Destiny is the person moralizing about
this, right? Like Destiny objectively
platformed this docs to a thousand times more people than are
in spicy chat. Like literally
>> You have a personal gripe. So inter your picture and
age. >> I don't have a personal gripe yet. >> How
did they get your picture? >> No, no, not my picture. They
got pictures from a stream and they got my age from a other chat
and then they reposted it in spicy chat. >> Yeah. So that
would be so that would be that would be doxing. So they wouldn't
have to moderate though.
>> It it is it is doxing. >> Wait, from what stream?
>> So no, not a stream. I'm saying like a chat. If somebody
finds my age >> No, I'm saying where they get your face.
>> If I've communicated with them, for example, I've communicated
with somebody like uh personally, right? >> Yeah. Where
did they get your face? >> I'm not talking I'm not talking
about my >> No, you said they posted a picture of your
face in the chat. I'm saying where did they acquire that photo?
>> It was an unlisted VOD. >> Okay. And they so it
was up >> it's a video on YouTube >> on your chat
even if it's unlisted you know people can access that right and
it was on your private channel >> right what I'm saying
is what do you consider doxing I guess is what I'm asking right
now >> I consider I cons oh yeah sure so I consider doxing
when you take personally identifying information from like a
separate source and link it to an >> so like a different
platform >> no no because if the platform is okay so what
I was about to say is it's when you take personally identifying
information and link it to somebody's private online identity
Right.
That was at one point a public video, right? That was uploaded
to your channel under your private under your identity. Um and
the video was up on list which is how they >> No, it wasn't
actually. It wasn't actually. It was from a um a channel that
I had not connected to my ducking >> How'd they find it?
>> Because it was attached to a profile that I commented
on. People looked at it and they linked it from one identity
to another. That is doc. >> So, wait. So, you linked the
two. >> No, no, no. I didn't link the two. People link
the two by association. >> Wait, how do they how did they
figure out it was you? >> Because of my online posting
history. What I'm explaining to you, Aiden, is that doxing can
be like a very simple thing. It could be >> That does that
does sound like it could possibly be >> No, no, no. That
sounds like it could possibly be doxing, but I don't know. I
don't know if the information So, I don't know how they found
it. I don't know exactly what happened here. This could be like
a a re she could have like a reasonable expectation that they
delete that for her depending on I I wouldn't say it's doxing
the same way. It's not like um it's not posting like
oh would it be it's not like welcoming additional harassment.
I don't know how to put it. It's like right on the line. You'd
have to know the exact circumstances of how this went about uh
how they went about this. Right. If it's like she she commented
on one of her own videos from an account that wasn't necessarily
connected and they thought it was. I don't know. >> Her
main was duck briger real and her second channel was duck briger
fake information from one space. Okay. It can be taking information
from one space. And by the way I don't have a very strong science
about doxing at all. I think that if you put anything online,
it should be able to be shared wherever. Which is why I think
the Willyback stuff is really stupid. >> Because this is
public information, >> Okay. Doxing. Almost all doxing.
Almost everything that is specifically doxing involves public
information. What matters is the public, like for example, here's
a good example. >> Tabulating it in in a in a consolidated
people to review people to review and click through and all linking
it to a private online persona. So, for example, if I have a
personal Facebook account with my full name on it, I'd be an
idiot for having that up. But if somebody was >> right
but even if I didn't have my full name on another account if
I had my if I didn't have my whole name like Aiden Aiden if I
didn't have my whole name on another account but it was still
there was still some information that could be linked to another
account right would that not be considered doxing for somebody
to take that private online account and link it to another >> depends
depends on depends on the context which you're being like kind
of like dodgy on. So what I want to know is for me to consider
the situation doxing I I want to ask some specific questions.
So what I want to ascertain here is >> how did they figure
out this account was yours? Um because they clicked through private
profiles that I had associated with through online name names
and like >> wait
that you had associated with online what online names >> right
so just um if you went in my discord and you looked at previous
aliases that I had used online you could find those and then
Google them and then you could find this count would that not
be doxing >> no if you if you've linked yourself
>> Why does everyone forget the key aspect of what doxing
is curation of uh and publishing of private of identifying information
with the express purpose to harass or organize harassment. So
I understand that Dracula, but
it is technically collecting it and posting it in spicy to kind
of with her specifically. I think I think
now they're not publishing it online and that is like a small
community. You could make like a little like you kind of make
an argument.
No one uses it that way. No, they definitely do. It >> to
that previous persona that would not >> I didn't link it.
You're Aiden. What I'm explaining to you is that you don't actually
follow the legal designation of >> Well, doxing isn't there's
>> just because information can be loosely linked online
interactions. If I said if I said this person online wait Aiden.
If I said, "Hey, I'm this person online and I'm also this person
online." If that was a relatively private conversation, there
could absolutely be considered like intent to do
the information. Wait, wait. Do you understand what doxing means?
Like, do you understand the actual definition of doxing? So,
so doxing has several definitions depending on what dictionary
you're looking at. It's a pretty new and like mostly informal
term despite cont despite popular opinion. It is not a >> but
what is what is it originally as? >> It's not legally defined
in the United >> Wait, when somebody was talking about
doxing, what were they talking about >> When you're linking
somebody's personally identifying information their online private
persona, >> it means documents docs. >> Nobody uses
Nobody Wait. Okay, that's Nobody uses
God.
This conversation is going to be funny. Oh my god, bro. Is it
like that though? That's not how it's used by
>> Doxing is revealing the public records of an individual.
Okay. >> That's that is part >> it is inherently
it is inherently a definition that the documents being public
under >> I would say for Yes. as uh as our friend I think
Benji just said no Dracula said for for the express purpose of
harassing somebody or organizing harassment against them. Right.
Like it would be linking these things, collecting these things,
but then publishing them to harass someone would be the would
be doxing. Just like collecting them is like h it's pretty weird,
but not that bad. If you collect it all and and publish it together
for the purpose of actually causing like real world consequences
to this person, I'd say that's obviously doxing is obviously
bad. Now,
do they want real world consequences? Do they want to with Duckbrer
that badly? I don't know. It's like right on the line where it
gets weird. So, one second.
>> Docbrer. duck under that definition. Okay. If somebody
was to document my previous live chats that I've made under this
account that I'm streaming on, that would be considered doxing.
>> Yes. Aiden, if somebody considered Okay, if you said
I live within 10 minutes of this thing and 10 minutes of within
this thing and 10 minutes within this business and somebody triangulated
your your like actual address based off that definition would
not consider that doxing because you have provided that information
publicly, right? >> No, you would have to No, because what
you would then have to do to get that Okay. Okay. So what you
would have to do to get that address is the information that
they've >> what you would have to do to get that address
to to make it doxing is to publish that address verify and publish
that address to get that person harassed. That's what that's
when it would become doxing >> provided to you on its own
does not establish that they live at such and such residence.
So they're not linking themselves to the giving information that
might aid that right like when I give out my age that doesn't
mean people can like that doesn't mean if someone goes through
and looks at like people born in such and such state to find
my like full docs and birth certificate. That doesn't mean it's
not doxing. it might help them in what >> so if I say on
a public on a sorry on a private chat that I am linked with this
profile
and somebody takes that >> and finds the profile >> access
to >> yes finds the profile is that not doxing that is
not doxing like if I said I live at such and such address and
somebody looks and somebody looks up the >> you're actually
okay what is your okay can I ask you something Aiden what do
you define as doxing define it for me right now in simple terms
so I've given you the definition like three times now I don't
know if you have bad memory but I'll say it again doxing is when
you were taking personally identifiable
What a catty this guy is >> information someone else's
personally identifiable information and linking it to somebody's
private online persona when that information was clearly not
meant to be linked or they've made an attempt to obscure it or
separate >> so anytime that somebody links two personas
online that is doxing right >> no if the person themselves
linked the personas that's personally identifying that's why
I said someone else identifying that's why I said someone else
that is personally identifying >> okay okay so can I give
you an example so under your definition if I have like a second
channel that I've linked on my YouTube channel. If people go
and say, "Look, this is Aiden's second channel. Look at what
he uploaded on there." That's obviously not doxing. Nobody uses
the term that way. >> Wait, but how did you Wait, how did
you link that channel? How was that channel >> Like, it'd
be in a URL in my descriptions. It would be um >> Okay,
in your in your active descriptions of your main channel. That's
not doxing. That's not what we're talking about. We're talking
about somebody finding and and tabulating information, right,
and consolidating it in a single spot to reveal your private
identity. To reveal your private identity to reveal
I get it. You do it. The is that >> your private identity?
What I'm telling you is that you tackle information to reveal
somebody's private identity. That is considered doxing. >> Okay.
Okay. >> So, okay. So, the medium of the way Okay. So,
for example, when you say this is my second channel, that's going
to differentiate from you linking it linking it on your channel
to such an extent where the difference between linking the two
will be doxing or not. >> No, no, the the difference is
what do you need to do to attribute the level of like like this
is this person's second channel like okay listen I'm sorry you're
kind of a little bit I'm not going to lie >> I'm saying
>> Hayden's getting rolled right now he's correct and he's
getting rolled >> exactly you don't understand what doxing
is you can't actually give me a definition on >> I've given
you a definition like four times what are you talking about >> you
haven't you haven't given me a single definition no >> I
haven't given you you actually have Alzheimer's you might >> I
don't Aiden's given her a definition. I thought he did. I thought
he said something about linking priv and private profiles or
personas, but now I really can't remember. I feel like he's just
getting totally destroyed right now. >> Like actually like
you need to get like check the grand in your brain is
>> who is this check? Uh dating Ros. I don't know much
about her. I kind of said I kind of laid it out that she's on
the pond scum podcast. She goes on there occasionally. I think
she used to be from boxes community. You know, >> information
from one space into another and it's all publicly available,
right?
>> Okay, let me give you example. >> All public available,
meaning you can find it on the public internet. Wait, wait, wait.
You can find it on the internet. Find the public internet and
you gather it all in one space. No, no, no. You find it on the
public internet and associate it with one single person. Shut
up, Michael. I go shut up.
>> He's uh he's not he's disturbed. He's
>> Okay. Um, so >> you are no longer Aiden. Okay.
>> Okay. Got it. Got it. Crusty the clown over here. >> You
are a different aame. >> Got it. Got it. >> So, if
you're finding information on the public internet and you are
tabulating it, okay, to associate it with a certain online identity
and you are constructing a case based off that, you don't consider
that doxing. >> Depends on the specifics. There would be
specifics there that would fit my definition and specifics that
wouldn't. I can tell you why yours wouldn't fit my definition
if you would listen. Okay. Go on. All right. So the reason as
I've defined about five times now, doxing is when somebody else
links your personally identifying information to your online
>> How do you define personal? Wait, you got to let me
finish. How do you wait? How do you identify [__]
Crazy [__] Can I finish a point? Can I finish a point?
Thanks. So >> I'm not a crazy you. >> Okay. So it
so when you create so somebody else establishing that link now
the example you've just given, you discuss in an accessible chat
that hey this identity over here is mine. You've created that
link. So that is not >> what is accessible. Do you consider
that publicly facing?
What do you mean publicly facing? >> Like what do you consider
accessible? You're using a lot of public. >> Sure. I I
don't know if you need a definition for accessible. Can any ordinary
member of the public access where this is being discussed? >> If
that's the case, then very little things are actually doxing
because a public a public member of the like if somebody's just
browsing the internet, there is a whole lot of information that
I can find and tabulate about your personal identity. >> No,
but the difference is that the difference is it wasn't intentional.
The difference is it wasn't intentional. You'll actually let
me finish which is why which is why in the fourth definition
I gave you actually let me finish the fourth definition I gave
you in the fourth definition I gave you if they made a reasonable
attempt to >> dude dude >> obscure themselves or
separate themselves from that information it's like clear they
don't want it linked to them um then yeah I also that doxing
even though it's technically public cuz most doxing involves
public info right >> if I am a member of a public that
has the ability to go on a website and find information about
you and tabulate it into one space is that called doxing answer
yes or no >> nope depends on details. It could be in some
cases, could not be in others.
>> So, what is the distinction? If I'm able to find information
that is public, what do you consider publicly available information?
Aiden, >> like anything that a member of the public can
access. But just because it's publicly available doesn't make
me public. Why can the member a member a member of the public
can literally access my private bank account that they want.
A member of the public can we could be watching a Dota 2 tournament
instead of this? Um, we could Is it on kick or is it on Twitch?
Hold on. Twitch. Twitch. Kick. Twitch. Twitch.tv.
Uh tw I didn't spell that correctly. twitch.tv. I'm just going
to go look. We'll see who's playing right now. We'll just see
who's playing real quick. Real quick. Real quick. Look.
Dod
do cop is watching extra. Dude, what? No, there's no good games.
This B cop watching whatever Chinese tournament this is. Remember
when this guy was like >> give me >> this guy was
like a reasonably good uh like caster and he just never got any
opportunities for some reason. This guy was like better than
everybody who was in the actual Dota caster cabal and he just
got totally This guy's like a way way way better caster than
so many people who actually got to cast Dota at like big tournaments.
>> Oh yeah, he just never got invited. >> Going to
the event. I regret missing
>> He was just he was like way better at streaming or at
casting than so many of the people. Lots of people don't even
know what I'm talking about. Meanwhile, down Llama down under
got a job. She did.
And Grant Grant justifiably bullied that off the internet. And
then Grant got cancelled. >> [__] Let me like
anything they want about me and they can document and they can
you are not actually letting me finish speaking. >> Ma'am,
all you've done is speak. I don't
>> I would hate to be residen. Aiden. Aiden. Aiden. >> Ma'am.
Ma'am, I think I think you need a Prozac. I think you need a
Prozac. >> Aiden. Yes. >> I'm literally talking over
you because you're not answering my question. Right. >> I'm
I'm trying.
>> You're not answering. A member of the public who is
able to find information on me, if they tabulate that information
and they they coalate it into one space, is that considered doxing?
A member of the public who has only access to publicly available.
>> Not necessarily. Not necessarily. The reason being that
you actually don't understand what doxing is. You don't have
a functional answer. You don't have you don't have an actual
factual definition of doxing. Your definition of doxing does
not actually allow for anybody to even
actionably
prosecute.
You realize that you talking over somebody does not make you
right. Right. >> I'm talking over you. Are you like >> You
can go. You can be so incredulous about what the I'm talking
about.
>> Shut the [__] up. Nobody cares. >> You're
like totally >> You can correlate information into one
space that is available publicly online and identify it as a
single person. Do you consider it doxing? >> No, not necessarily.
The reason being, right, if the person themselves established
the link to that public information like willingly, then no.
>> How do they establish that link? How do they establish
that link, Aiden? How do they say identifying information online
by personally releasing personally identifying ma'am by releasing
personally identifying ma'am I'm trying to answer information
online that you are opening yourself up to doxing that is not
supposed to like Okay I'm trying to answer your question I'm
trying to answer your question I'm trying to answer what you
are saying Aiden is basically there's no definition of doxing
there is no definition of doxing that will apply based off your
definition you [__] [__] >> have
you ever watched the movie misery you kind of see >> there
is no definition of doxing that will apply to your definition
because basically I >> Aiden's just totally right now.
Like he's just completely I don't know. I've never seen Aiden
lose harder in a debate than he's losing to Duckwinger right
>> The public a public individual can go and coate any
information that I want about a private individual and post it
and associate it with their online anonymous persona. >> They
associate.
>> He had to he had to drop from the call just to just
to stop getting railed. >> Holy [__] Shut the
[__] up, >> dude. She didn't even get phased.
He came back in. Oh, whoops. Sorry.
No, no, no. Shut up, Aiden.
>> Based on public information. Shut the up. Don't talk
over me for like 10 seconds, okay? Based on public information
that somebody has released. You're telling me, >> you know
what, Dr. Brier, you're right. Why would he talk over you? Why
would he talk over you? You've You've not gotten any time to
speak in this debate so far. >> If somebody has the ability
online as a public individual to go and find all the information,
tabulated, >> we need this person in the Discord >> and
collect it in one spot. That is not doxing. That's what you're
saying.
>> Oh, this guy's such a catty. And it might not be the
reason being right in >> Oh my god. You absolute [__]
coward.
>> 4 seconds. 4 seconds where she
>> that's crazy.
>> I was trying to give an answer. I timed it cuz I want
to see how long before she cuts me off. How long did she answer
a question?
It cuts me off. Dude, what is wrong with this person? Oh my god.
This person's like a nutcase, dude. >> Actual worthless
human. You should You serve zero purpose, Aiden. You should get
yourself now.
>> Actual [__] like nut job. Holy [__]
>> Uh, that's good. That's >> dude. Somebody needs
to say
it's it's not it's not just like it's not just >> she rejoins
and then I believe apologized to Yoko. It is not Yokoono. Okay.
It is it's like Annie from from
>> You ever seen that movie? You ever seen that movie?
That's literally what she sounds like. >> A just got his
cheeks ruthlessly clapped. Lose your movie. She ran. Okay. She
ran pointed my answer. POV
and I answer and like 4 seconds. He's like screaming over. Holy,
>> bro. He's so rattled. He's now just coping about it
in the He's just coping about it to his chat.
>> He's He's just rattled. He got destroyed and he's rattled
and he's coping about >> Let me make this clear since she
didn't give me an opportunity to answer. Information being public
or not is not going to be the qualifier for me as to whether
or not something is doxing. It is how the link between that public
information was established to one's private online identity.
If somebody under their private online identity said this public
information is mine then no invoking that would not be doxing
because they established the link not
Very simple answer. Okay very simple answer. So the determinant
factor for it being doxing or not is not the publicity of the
information but rather how the link between that information
and one's private online persona is established. >> Any
questions? Yo I need to call someone. There's a call I need to
make. Hold on. She's like actually crazy dude. Holy [__]
What it's going to take to
dude? Holy [__] Do I get it now,
dude? Of course. I' I've called her crazy for a long time.
This is like, dude. Holy [__] You know what? I don't
feel so bad about being single now.
>> Oh, I just know I didn't even see his name in chat.
It's Queen Dog catcher. No, it's dog.
>> Okay. I don't know what the context correction is something
that was being said. It seems
>> been quoting the or correcting the what do you call
it? >> One of the Hassan things something about the lowest
dog catcher used to be the lowest elected office. >> Well,
let's get into our Brad.
>> Let me try to ring resi. Okay, I'm let me try to ring
resi real quick. I want to see if resi will pick up. >> I
didn't scan the des content. The person who donated for all of
it said watch whatever. We're watching this and
and we're going to cover it tomorrow. I think I think I'll cover
it tomorrow. We'll see. We'll see what happens. and like clearly
unwell that you like couldn't ask questioning for 4 seconds.
Yeah, I timed it on stream. The answer to your question was something
being public or not is not the determinant factor for whether
or not something qualifies as toxing under my definition. What
matters the qualifying factor would be how was the link between
this public information and this private online persona established.
Okay, that's going to be the determinant factor for whether or
not it's toxic. If it was a case of you clearly were not making
an effort to link this to yourself and just literally winning
from the chat and links it to the chat. If it's a case of you
creating that link yourself
>> you under your online persona link yourself to this
public information whe
it you linked it and again
is I go crazy.
>> Aiden Aiden
>> come out and play. Hey. >> Hello. Hello. Are you
there? Are you with us? Me? >> Aiden. Aiden is openly and
intentionally
walking down valley right now. Okay. We watched what happened
to him five minutes ago. He is making that choice. He has taken
a hard 90°ree right turn down valley and we all see what's happening.
He cannot complain for the outcome. Okay. About the outcome.
Can't complain about it at all. >> No. Yes. Yes. You. What
do you want? You're in my callins. Oh, okay. Yeah. So, do you
think that like see you think I'm crazy, right? But like because
I argue very passionately, right? >> It was just you argue
passionately.
You ask a question and then you're like unable to hear an answer
like that's why things passion argue. You like can't emotionally
train yourself for like four seconds. Hear the answer. >> Go
ahead. >> Hello. Like you could acknowledge I was talking
previous times we spoke over. >> Hello. Hi. >> Hi.
So, um I'm asking you because you seem to criticize me and you
criticize me over one conversation we had by the way which I
you see that um
>> that's awesome. Oh, she >> converation had you
decided to go on a public space and give your opinion about me,
right? You thought that I was toxic for Resi. That was crazy.
What do you think about Igo? What do you think about Igo's associations
with people around >> Yeah, I don't know a lot about her,
but she seems fine. >> You don't know a whole lot about
her, but you swept for her twice. You swept her in the smug debate.
You swept for her in the >> in the smug bug debate. You
were you were moderator, but you weren't really a moderator,
right? We're talking about the whole the whole where she was
trying to figure out where the leaks of some information went
to or or came from when it came to the Shrader raid uh Pixie
stuff. You remember that? >> Uh yeah, when I was modering
the combo between her and Riyle. >> Mhm. You were moderating
combo between her and Ryle. >> Yes. You remember that you
basically inserted your own arguments in the conversation and
you kind of helped her arguments as a moderator. You were kind
of sleeping for one
>> be concerned that there's a notable drop in intelligence
among DGG proxies. Should I be concerned? I don't know you boy
schemed. I don't know. I don't think Duckbringers DG proxy or
anything like >> Second of all, right, I interjected on
both sides behalf in the context of discussion to like establish
something.
Oh, speaking of DGG people though, okay, did you guys see the
DGER that got caught? Know a lot of people on here were mutuals
with Jared Kelly, especially in the Destiny orbit. Well, he stop
he stopped posting a few months ago and I got curious. Turns
out he's
cam videos by the way. Prominent DGER.
Super prominent DGER.
300 pedophile videos. Bruh Icarus follows this guy. A lot of
people follow this guy. A lot of lot of people follow this guy.
Hello. Who's this? >> J Stalk. Jared Kelly follows me on
Twitter and I just want to say he's been charged, not convicted.
And just hear me out on this, okay? Just hear me out. >> Listen,
I know that you got touched as a kid, so you feel a lot of empathy
for this guy. And I know that Duckbringer just touched you again,
okay? I saw we're watching this right now, so I understand why
you'd have a lot of empathy for this guy, but I do not. I just
ted. Someone told me you were on Duckbringer's side. I was a
little >> Yeah, Duckbrer is totally bogging you right now.
Like you've lost entirely.
You in you pulling her back into your main channel after her
first call in is like you walking down Valley. >> Got it.
Got it. Um
I I don't really know how to refute
>> You know, with like database leaks and stuff, it's like
pretty easy to tie mo like most online accounts to like people's
real identities, right? like usually have password matches, email
matches across like multiple databases. So like realistically
the the public private link just because somebody was like sloppy
with one link, I don't think that mean makes it not doxing, right?
>> What no it's not when you intentionally say that this
is mine like when when it's intentional when you've intentionally
established that link. It's not just like negligence, right?
Intent. You've established the link >> What like you accidentally
leave something? What's what's intention? So intention would
be like if I clearly am if I'm clearly
uh knowingly letting if I'm knowingly
saying that this account is mine like I'm I'm it's like purposeful.
It's not like I accidentally show it on stream. Um I'm saying
it under the impression that saying this will let the public
know that this account belongs to me. >> Sorry. Say all
that again. I I'm so sorry. Can you say that? >> Yeah.
I'm a little bit I apologize.
I'm a little bit uh drunk right now, but
>> Sorry, I'm not here for Listen, I don't want to be accused
of running. Um, but uh can we like do this? Like, if you want
to actually debate me on this, we like do it tomorrow. >> I
don't really No, I don't really want to debate. It's It's I'm
not like I don't have a super strong position. I don't think
you're wrong or anything. I just think Duckbringer mogged you
like uh like her she or mogged you like super hard. Like literally,
you could have been she could have been arguing like 1 plus 1
is three and you still would have lost because she ora mogged
you so hard, you know. True. True. True statements being made.
You do have a you do have a predilation aside with uh women that
have diagnoses that make up half the DSM. So, fair enough. Fair
enough, >> Uh-huh. Okay. Good luck. >> Enjoy enjoy
your stream. >> Bye. I really did. You did not intervene
on side at all. Wait, are you kidding? We should intervene on
wild side.
>> I just want to I just want to point out that Aiden had
to take a swing at a woman. Okay. He had to take a swing at a
woman instead of me.
Kind of kind of
>> You're wear you're wearing
somebody else, right? >> I can tell you exactly where her
van was. It seemed like I think it was like a malicious point
or whatever. She was saying she didn't think it was malicious
or something like that. She her story didn't match like the mouth.
No, you didn't match. Speaking of siding with people with, you
know, questionable proclivities. Okay, back to the guy Aiden
was just defending the DJ Ger with over 300 Cam videos. Okay,
a lot of these people are following this guy. Okay, and I just
got to point out, there's just one thing I got to point out with
this. Okay, in the world of online content,
judge me by my enemies, okay? Just judge me by my enemies. All
right, that's all I'm saying. Jared Blanco reposted some Willie
Mack cope about how he didn't make a single good point. Even
though he totally said, "Yeah, I absolutely concede on this point
you made about Kelly." "Oh yeah, I should have asked Destiny
for some evidence." Totally conceded on that.
And unfortunately, even though he made that concession, he couldn't
remember that concession long enough to ask Destiny for evidence
of anything else. Destiny said, "Ly Slackjaw having a rough go."
Okay,
Lily Slackjaw has got the support of a lot of sorry, a lot at
least one credibly accused. So, historical revisionism because
he knows people won't check. Yeah, I know.
It's fine. Listen, Willie was on borrowed time at this point
anyway, guys. Willie was on borrowed time. It's all good. Well,
it's not really a good bad look for Willie. I would just say,
you know, the DG or probably many such cases. Okay. Probably
many such cases. I just think I just think it's funny. That's
all. Unlucky. I just think it's funny. It doesn't actually mean
anything. I
>> did not call her out. She had that trial. What was the
point of her calling out straight raid? Can you elaborate that
to me, Aiden? What was the point of calling straight? >> Uh,
I don't know. It was probably because she >> had 9 hours
of >> All of the Pon Scum people will defend Straight Raid
like totally totally endlessly forever. Straight raid actually
pulls all the strings behind Pon Scum. Okay. All of these people
will defend her until the ends of the earth. >> Content
trying to say how straight raid should not be in the space drama.
Yeah, I'm aware of you don't want your content
>> Wait, why am I actually engaged with the topics that
you care about? 30-y old 30-year-olds are not my type. I'm sorry
to tell you. Like, no, I wasn't. >> She's 40, by the way.
40. Got it. All >> My type. >> Out of Perry's range,
even. Okay. So, what did Strade do that required Igo to stream
for three days in a row over her content, saying that it was
weird that she was [__] in these spaces? Do you like
that was what the actual argument was about? It was about straight
raid and about where the leaks came from. You understand how
people lied about where the leaks came from, right? Maybe they
did, maybe they didn't. I don't really >> didn't Aiden
get groomed by a much older guy? Weren't 30-year-olds his type
back >> They definitely did, but do you understand why
they lied and why they lied to IO specifically? >> Uh,
no. I don't really care. It's because IO can't be trusted with
information about private individuals. Okay. And there was a
private individual in the middle of all of that. >> So,
okay. Um, cool. >> So, if you want to know, >> I
actually don't know that guy's age. Could be 25. I have no idea
about that
He's the person who apparently had information that Becket was
interested in or he got from Becket or whatever. You were part
of this drama. The fact you don't know about it. >> Where
was I part of this? Honestly, to your mal I know. I know Aiden's
19.
had no so you had no information on what you're moderating is
what you're telling >> No, not really. You don't need it,
right? You can just you can just what you do is what you do is
>> you can't moderate off vibes, dude. Because if you basically
both sides both sides combat, whoever is the most persuasive,
you kind of go with them. But the problem is just because somebody's
persuasive does not mean they have the correct argument. So if
you're moderating, your intention is actually to steer against
that like that that direct like current, right? So
in the moment I would ask people to substantiate certain claims
like a clip or a piece of evidence and then when they substantiate
that we would pull up and review. Uh-oh. I didn't realize I joins.
Oh, what do we got for time here, guys? Got 11 minutes. I'm not
going to end right here. Not quite right here. >> So, like
with that whole I >> I'm not going to make it all the way
through this. We've got uh we've got like another hour of content
here. Another like hour and a half of content here. So, resi
joins eventually.
>> Mug. Um, >> stick it out. We're not doing the
whole thing. I'm sorry. You guys want to pay for more time, you
pay for more time. What do you think about all that? What is
your opinion? >> I don't have an opinion. I don't know
too much about it. Okay. So, do you think it was important to
figure out who leaked those messages to begin with? >> For
me, no, not really. >> Right. So, you actively facilitated
Iiko's stupid drama that she was farming that had nothing to
do with anything. >> Well, what I facilitated was I facilitated
mad vibes on getting mad
was getting
I was talking. Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. Shut
up. What are you not talking? What are you not saying? You like
the sound of your own voice. You're such a narcissistic little
[__] What are you not speaking? I thought you go
on. >> I'm not narcissistic. You sit here and you having
a discussion. Why are you using therapy terms? >> Aiden,
why are you using therapy terms like a woman? >> Therapy
terms. I narcissist.
>> Jesus Christ.
Champion. Thank you for the gifted son. Narcissist. I'm a narcissist.
Every
No, because you're sitting here complaining about Let me talk.
Let me talk. You've spoken for like 99% of these combos and you
like can't pick up on the fact a lot about >> the testosterone
made Britney very ornery. Okay. Testosterone made her very
I don't know that we're ever getting the old Britney back. >> Stuff
you clearly have no interest in because you you moderated a debate
that you don't have any information on. You just admitted that.
>> True. True. >> So why did you insert yourself
in the middle of the situation that you have no being in? Because
you wanted attention, right? You wanted this, right? >> So
So what I know is >> So why am I talking? >> So you
asked me a question. You don't let me answer it. >> Okay.
So I know how arguments are >> Cut him off. Cut him off
again, Ducker. Cut him off again. You have the power. You've
got him on the ropes. Do not let him speak. >> I know to
follow a line of logic. I know how when like when someone's premises
does not like does not add to their conclusion. So what I do
is even if I don't know about the subject on hand, I'll have
two people with two opposing sides make points against one another
and I'll have them substantiate it with evidence live on the
stream. Right? So even if it's not just about persuasion, the
evidence also comes into play which I think even after this thing
got pulled up some like Ry conceded on one thing after a clip
got pulled up that he was referencing and it both sides what
I asked both sides what I asked both sid you shut the up for
two seconds. What I asked both sides what I asked both sides
when we were done is do you feel like I'm fair to you in this
debate? Do you feel like my and they both agreed that I was they
didn't take issue with it. The audience didn't take issue with
my performance. It's seemingly only you. I think it's because
you're like obsessed with Io. You like this like weird deranged
like hate of Io. Trust me, I'm not obsessed with Io. I go is
obsessed with me. It's the other way around. She seems to think
You want to talk about this? You want to talk about this in
thinks that I I go thinks that Resi is in love with her and it's
kind of funny as [__] to me. Can I just say that
she actively conspires? >> Oh god. Ah,
>> I hate this suddenly. Oh, I hate this. I hate it. I
hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate Do
you think that I said that Perry that I was with Perry because
the DMs? Do you understand? Do you understand?
>> Oh no. >> Do you understand what the AHA DMs were
>> DMs. The aha DMs. What are the AHA DMs? Can somebody
tell me >> and Harry? I was laughing at him for the Marcus
stuff because the Marus stuff and I realized his
Inquisition. No, it lines up perfectly. It lines up perfect.
Why would I ever flirt with Harry? By the >> Did he say
Did she just say Cunny Inquisition? Please tell me she did not
just say Cunny Inquisition. >> The way Perry is a fat [__]
lower box te
when the fation was happening. So you didn't [__]
know that at the time matter. I had nothing to do with him. You
can actually Why are you invoking that? Oh my. You're so [__]
dumb. Why are you invoking that? Why you invoking how you looked
after
the jam? >> Perry's not fat. I've seen Perry. Perry's not
fat, is he? >> I could have sworn I just looked at Perry
yesterday. What?
Hold on. Where's the picture I had of Perry? Somebody sent me
a picture from his live stream yesterday.
I'm trying to Let me just find it. Oh, I don't have it in my
DMs anymore. God damn it.
>> You realize I go You realize I go as a 40-year-old Aiden.
You realize I go a 40-year-old woman and she's blocking. She's
like pocket watching my relationship to She's pocket watching
my >> I'm pocket watching my relationship. Aiden, Aiden,
you're sweeping. You're sweeping hero right now. You're sweeping
hero. You're sweeping hero.
I think I'll say the thing about Perry. Okay. I don't I don't
want to talk Perry, but he's got like a certain There is almost
like a I don't want to say it. I feel like it's up to say it.
Hold on. Let me Let me see. Can we pull up the Perry cam here?
Where's the Perry cam? Mr. Girl thing. Pull it up if I can find
a picture of him. It's not this one. See got his picture up here.
Oh, >> no. No one wants the time. >> Wait, he argued
with the Zip Zip guy about something. Why was he on this Discord?
Oh, this is like What is this? >> Oh, it's his BRB screen.
Never mind. Unlucky. Unlucky.
>> Why can't I find a Perry a Perry Cam stream right now?
I'm looking at my other monitor. There it is. You're saying like
this guy's fat. >> Who's the person? >> This guy's
not fat. >> Leaked the nudes and tapes of Pixie with as
well as numerous other people. They try figuring out if they're
a minor. They tried figuring out if they're minor. And the answer
is probably yes, by the way. The rose person probably is
>> That's not I don't know that. Sorry. I'm just I'm just
defending a brother out here. Okay. >> For Igo, why are
you sweeping for Igo? Why are you sweeping for a 40-year-old
Spencer right now? >> I barely know her. Why would I sweep?
>> Why are you sweeping for a 40-year-old Spencer that
needs validation to people like Queen? Why are you doing that?
>> Why would I sweep? I barely know her. You sound You
literally sound obsessed. You actually sound obsessed with this
person. It seems unhealthy. >> I am not obsessed with Iiko.
Do you realize that Io has been messaging
>> I don't think like I obviously disagree with Io in the
straight raid stuff like completely, but it's not like I'm like,
"Oh, I like a total for thinking whatever she think." I don't
just don't >> That I know to try to get me and my boyfriend
to break up. Like who >> is that not weird to you? >> Like
who? >> Like everybody in commentary. Like she's been telling
everybody in commentary that I'm a weird person. She's been telling
everybody in commentary.
>> Uh you should you should literally barely even say this.
You should say it one time and then you should present the
>> She's the one that Aiden. She's the one that started.
>> Dude, I need to get this down.
>> That's uh that's awesome. >> Give me a person.
He's been telling everybody that she's the one that Aiden, she's
the one that started. I can't even I can't even do it. I am the
reason. Did I not Aiden? Did I not DM you about the fact that
Aiden did not DM you? Aiden, did I or did I not DM you? >> Name
one. You did me after my first DM. You me a few days ago after
my combo I go on stream. Now, my question for you is name one
person I just did not DM you. Name one. Name one. I just said
you did. Now name one. Name one. Nameug. Nope. Time for my question.
Time for my I didn't read it. Time for my question. >> Wait,
did she message Smug and Whiz about this? Was she in Smug's DMs?
I wouldn't think she'd be in Smug's DMs after their blowup. >> I
answered
>> Whiz and Smug and Resi >> and you and Wait, she
didn't message Wait, she didn't message me? >> Yes, she
did. She messaged all those people. Do you realize that I have
a DM message to break up? I'll share my DMs right now. >> Do
you realize that I have a message from Resi of Ieko saying, "Why
don't you control your because I commented on Perry and Chudlogic
Jr. Chudlogic Junior funeral?" I said, "Rip Chud Logic." And
I go send resi a DM saying, "Why is Duckbringer still replying
in Perry's DMs or Perry's chat?" You realize that's the insanity
that I had to deal with. Wait, wait, wait. I want you to acknowledge
that. Okay. How insane is >> Poor Boohoo. Boohoo. It's
not that >> It's not. Wait, I go. It's not I go. You're
honestly just >> You got I go on your mind all the time.
It's crazy because you are a little feckless that actually only
cares about your platform. You don't care about truth. You don't
care about the truth. You don't care about humanity. You only
care about humanity. Truth. I don't I don't care about humanity.
I do care about the truth because if I didn't care about the
truth, it would actually hurt my platform. So, I do care about
the >> You take ADHD meds. >> Uh, no. Why? >> You
sure? >> No. Why? >> If you do, I'm just telling
you, you should probably lower your dose. >> You kind of
like argue in like a circle like a bunch of Vance people do.
>> You haven't even heard my argument because you're like
so emotional. You're like having a oneway like a monologue. >> I'm
not having a monologue or anything. >> You are. It's okay
though. >> You are saying this because you can't actually
engage with the argument that I'm having. >> I can. Every
time I try cut off for a dumb Spencer who has no points about
anything that she's making and the only reason that you guys
validate her is because it's funny to you. >> What do you
mean validate her? I validate individual arguments she's made
if I think they're correct. >> What argument has she made
recently that's correct? >> Uh I don't know. Like on the
stream with Ry, she made several arguments that I sided with
cuz I thought >> what like what >> for example for
I think one of them. Sure. So I can't like explain like every
cuz I don't talk to her that much. We had a conversation then
and then once on stream so I don't know like the specifics of
everything but the only times I've spoken to her in like the
context of it's in the context like arguments with other people
mostly and each time I'll like agree or disagree with certain
point she's making I don't remember the specifics of every point.
>> Okay. So you don't remember a single argument that you
agreed or disagree with Iiko. You just remember that you supported
one side or the other. >> Yeah. On like a specific point
as we went down the points. >> Yeah. You're kind of >> like
I think I think there was one kind of just like validating people
based off >> What was that? Rob J. Hammond. Thank you for
the two gifted
we are
we 12 subs away for another hour if you guys wanted it. You don't
have to want it. We'll go for a little bit longer than just the
uh the one minute left. >> I know cuz I think there no
if you
do agree a natural stop and I like I >> So why did you
agree with her in the conversation with Riy which is about straight
raid? >> I didn't agree in the I agree on like >> duck
is so disgusting with how she talks about Iiko.
Uh, I just think it s I would say it feels like she should be
she should have evidence that she's ready to post if she's going
to say these things because otherwise it's extremely easy for
people to just write her off as jealous, right? If you're going
to say these things about Iiko, oh, she's messaging everybody
and doing all this. You should have something cuz otherwise it
just comes off as jealousy, right? Like paranoid jealousy. So
if you assuming you care about people thinking that about you,
you should just have the evidence there. I'm not even saying
that like I don't think it's possible without her evidence or
something like I I don't really feel the need to write people
off like that. But uh that's going to be the easiest thing in
the world for most of the people who do this kind of thing like
Aiden >> or I go make go ahead explain what point did I
go make that you that you agreed >> Like for example her
saying something was like close to malice didn't necessarily
equate to her saying something was malicious.
>> What did Wait, straight raid was doing something malicious?
What was she? >> I don't I don't think I think she I don't
know.
>> That's not That's not what it was saying. That's an
incredibly abstract argument. Why the could you even cite >> It
wasn't. I don't think she was. >> Okay. You're Aiden, you're
not.
>> Hey, you guys had a talk. You guys had a debate or you
moderated a debate where I was arguing that like Shraider was
uh like the bad actor here, the worst actor here. And it's like,
well, what Aiden's like, I agreed with some of her arguments.
It's like, which ones? Oh, a totally like a totally abstract
like semantic semantics based argument that had nothing to do
with like the actual content of the debate or at the actual like
facts of the debate, >> dude. Okay, >> not making
a good argument right now. Why argument did I go make straight
raid? That's the point is that you're just kind of like you're
kind of jumping at one thing or the other
not really having a strong
>> Yeah, Lambertainment I I realized I think we argued
it on my stream or in some call. It was mostly on my stream where
resi and
resi and Perry started arguing over this with Duckbringer and
Ieko and Ieko came in and I and resi were arguing and >> I
remember that happening
wherever
that's why you don't have sure so you're the one making the positive
claim. So let me ask you name a time I agreed with Iiko where
I did not provide any basis for my agreement.
>> I don't know I'm not making that >> You are you
just argued there with the vibes. That's what you just said >> because
I you're you're asking me to illustrate to you a argument that
you didn't make. That's what I'm telling you. I'm telling you.
You didn't make an argument. You didn't make the argument in
support of what was saying. >> Excuse me. You were literally
claiming that I was shifting to IEO. You literally came in here
and said I swept for IEO in that conversation. You said that
you brought Eeko up and now you're saying that I just like agree
with based on vibes, right? So agreeing based on vibes means
my my agreement has little to no substance. So I'm asking you
I'm asking you.
So I'm asking you the question. So the question the question
illustrate to me what the argument was making that you can illustrate
the argument that you were that I was making that you agree with
illustrate
that you agree with
you have [__] you have to gaslight crazy
trying to convince you you're crazy you're crazy yeah everyone's
trying to convince you you're crazy
you're the only one you agree with >> so so so the question
>> Aiden's not doing Aiden needs to do like 1970s
misogynistic woman down talking. Okay, sweetheart. You just you
just need a drink. Just take a drink. Just take a drink. Okay,
you just take a drink. You're histrionic right now.
>> Did you make am I mind your abusive crying? I literally
>> have you thought about Have you thought about getting
a hobby? Have you just thought Maybe you just need to like Should
I buy you something? I I don't know why. I just get the feeling
that that would calm her down. >> What are you doing now?
You're trying to invoke me. So my question
actually
argument that I can make that you agree with. >> I don't
care that your ex abused you. First of all, second of all, what
I was trying to ask you was you're the one that came in here
with the argument, the positive argument that I sway with people
to people based on vibes, right? And what did I go that you agree
with? >> I'm not done talking. I'm not I'm not done speaking.
>> What argument did I go make that you agree with? >> So
So okay, honestly, guys, I tried it hard not to punch you in
the face. Holy [__] So the thing that I had said
was So the thing I'm glad >> you're like one bad relationship
away from being a woman. >> I'm glad Aiden, what do you
I'm glad I'm Well, I wouldn't be in a relationship with somebody
to begin with, but I'm very like >> Yeah, you would be
relationship,
>> dude. How How did Aiden get so blown out? I told you.
I could tell he was walking down Rick Valley. It was over.
>> So my argument Okay. Any pronouns any all pronouns.
So my question argument that I make that you agree with about
straight raid it's a simple question dodging you are making the
argument you're making the argument you're dodging you're dodging
you're dodging you actually
dodging >> I don't listen
>> dude she's she's got my spirit in her that's what I
did to Destiny
you just got raped
the someone pointed this out earlier too he tries to do the the
Sunday ma'am Madam, madame. Madame, but he's got like a very
like he doesn't have the voice for it, right? >> Ma'am,
ma'am, ma'am, ma'am.
>> Dude, ma'am, what? >> So, can I So, can I So,
can I ask you a question? So, I want to ask you >> So,
my question for you is since you're the one making the argument,
name an agreement. At time, I agree with Eeko when I provided
no substance for my agreement. If you're presenting the argument
that I shift to her solely off of vibes. >> So, you're
asking me to explain it. Can you ask the question? I'll tell
you what. I want you to do what I'm asking you to do since you're
arguing that I should based on asking me anything.
So what I'm asking you to do is I'm asking for you to provide
an example where I agreed with Iiko and did not provide a reason
for it in the context of that debate where I did not provide
a reason for it because you're claiming I just
me being around Re's neck and Yoko Uno. >> So okay I talking
about the Riyle Io debate but I could talk about that one too.
So the reason for that is I think >> Why do you think I
have a weight around Res's neck? >> Cuz I think you're
insane. You think doesn't have the ability to make his own his
own decisions? >> Yeah, he can. I've seen men do crazy
things for So the the I think that like you're like insane. >> So
you think [__] you think is a like a a corrupting
factor in in men? Do you think that any man that is with a woman
is corrupted? >> Not any. Wait, no. Not obviously not any.
How do you >> But only But if a man is with a woman that
you disagree with, they're corrupted. If a man is with a woman
that you disagree with, they're corrupted. That's what you're
saying. That's what you're saying. >> I'd love to hear
Aiden's uh Aiden's thought. What I'm saying is what I'm saying
is I think men are willing to look past red flags if the is good.
That's what I'm saying. >> Right. Why do you think this
is good with me? >> I I can't see any other motive he would
stay with you. >> You don't think that the fact that
and he's like and he has all these special he has like self control.
He has like self control. He has self control. You
>> this is like a very weird conversation. You have you
have and honestly I'm so happy I am when I meet people like you.
What kind of woman would you want to be >> I'm so I'm so
happy you're a What kind of woman do you want to be? How [__]
stupid are you? That's the dumbest >> That's what I'm saying.
You are an person making a remark of a relationship as if you
are [__] actual
[__] Excuse me. Your point is
you're saying that you wouldn't be with anybody. You wouldn't
be with anybody. You wouldn't be with anybody. But being with
me would be too bad for you. >> Madam, I'd like to give
you a standing ovation for realizing that people don't want to
be with women. Honestly, props to you. Great genius observations
being made tonight. >> People don't want to be with women.
Why don't you want to be with women? >> I'm not a So I
could be with a woman and I I probably might. >> Okay.
And if you were with a woman, what do you think? What what would
uh like what about being an opinionated person? Frightens you.
>> No, I want her to be opinionated. If she's not opinionated,
>> I want a woman to be opinionated. You don't want her
to say her opinions online if you have a career? >> No.
No. I do want her to say her opinions, but I want her to like
>> What's wrong with me, Aiden? What the [__]
is wrong with me? >> Sure. I'll tell you exactly what's
wrong with you. You can't exercise self-control. You make an
argument, ask for an answer, and then don't wait for the response,
and cut it off while simultaneously complaining about interruption.
So, you're a total egocentric hypocrite. Um, you are >> No,
I interrupt you because you're actually not making points. You're
obiscating your point. You're obiscating your point. You're doing
it right now. >> I don't interrupt all the time. >> I
think it's really gross that Aiden won't actually address her
points that he's just like trying to be misogynistic and a little
bit like ableist or, you know, he's like totally just denigrating
her instead of actually engaging with her arguments, which is
how you know he's losing the debate really, right? Like, he will
not engage with any argument she's made. All he does is talk
over her and then after he talks over her, he just he just goes
and like starts saying massages. You're a crazy [__]
You're a crazy. You're a crazy like I've never seen a bigger
loser in a debate. It's crazy. >> People like people like
you people like and you cried on one of them. You can put on
people like Io not leaving you alone yet to hear a random I was
reliving my abuse. Aiden, do you realize that I was reliving
that abuse? >> If you're reliving your abuse in like a
debate, you should be realized. No. Do you realize about it?
If you're reliving, if you're reliving, >> do you realize
that if you're living in the context of then leave? Exercise
self control and leave. >> I should have done that, but
leave. Leave now. Leave. >> Aiden, do you realize that
Perry was asking about the abuse for the first time that I had
ever actually talked about it? >> I knew I knew Aiden was
a son at all. So, how did he know you were abused? So, how did
he know you were abused? >> Because I do you know
>> uh I'm sorry. I would love to hear Perry. Perry would
have the most deranged answer on planet Earth for that
I I would just want to I know Perry's probably answered that
question somewhere.
He would have the most deranged answer to that question. I just
I would want to know what it is. >> You know what? Do you
do you know why he knew I was abused? Because I said to Perry
in a private DM, I said, "Hey, if you yell at me on my stream,
I am probably
the out and not be able to have a productive conversation with
you."
Shut the
Madam she's she's like Goku powering up right now. She's going
super sick.
Madam
I don't care.
Madam Madam
the abuse the first time that I
don't care. I don't
madam.
I don't care.
>> the fact that I said the word abusive on stream and
I said yeah I did at first associate with you with this thing
that I had just you said abusive on streaming >> No no
no. I said abusive in a DM and I deleted it. Perry brought up
the fact that I used the word abusive on stream.
>> So when he did that, okay, I said yes, you're right.
I used the word abusive. I deleted it because I realized it was
a charged word. I did not want that to to be part of the conversation.
The reason that I said that to Perry was because he had illustrated
to me. He had he had intimated to me in the conversation we had
on my stream that he was uncomfortable with how I was going about
yelling at him. >> Yes. Okay. I took that I took that sincere
which I took that s sincerely because I had a friend who was
a popular streamer who told me he thought he was sincere. Somebody
who knew Perry personally. I'm not going to reveal this person's
name. They knew Perry personally and they said I think Perry
is sincere about that. So I sincerely messaged Perry and I said
hey yelling is a problem for me. If you don't like the fact that
I yelled back at you don't yell at me because I am probably going
to yell because I have this in my history is a problem. That
was a mistake of mine. I understand that now. So, I spoke to
you and I feel like I think you preemptively to justify your
behavior, but what I but I spoke to you in a normal time. >> Um,
do we already shield? I shield a little bit. I'm fine with we'll
find a natural stopping point for this if we don't hit the goal.
>> I will take off though a little bit of time from the
Yeah, I spoke to you after he know about the abuse beforehand
because you sent him a DM. >> No, that was after a conversation.
I had I had a conversation with him on stream. I sent that DM
and then he told me to come on Queensman's to discuss my DMs.
That's the That's the timeline of events. I thought he brought
your abuse up on stream. >> He did. >> So if the
DM If the DM happened after the stream, how would he know about
it during that stream? >> The DM happened. No, no, there
was a stream on my stream. Perry and I DM'd between that and
then Perry said, "Hey, Queen actually is the one that reached
out to me and said, "Hey, I really want to litigate this thing
between you and Perry. Let's smooth things over." He was >> very
about that, by the way. So I get the live stream, hey, there's
some concerning No, no, no. There's some >> Docbrer's got
an issue with trimmers being deceptive with her. It's a it's
a problem between you and Duck. I said, "Listen, just go ahead
and release the DMs. Whatever the you want to do, if that's what
this conversation is going to be about, just release the DMs."
Right? What I didn't realize is that Perry had noticed that I
said abusive X in my original message. And I very quickly, like
within a minute of sending that message, edited the message to
remove the word ab
What was that? I just got some subs.
It's a little chunk. Five gifted from Space Ghost. Let's go.
Thank you very much, Space Ghost. Appreciate My ex-boyfriend
yelled at me a lot. It's abuse for me. >> What do we got?
We got zero on the >> Beat the out of me until I was bleeding
>> You're bleeding internally. Christ. I wasn't cry. I'm
not I I cried about that when Perry asked me to relive that on
stream. It was the first time that I ever had rethought about
that and it was hard for me and I did cry. I did that. >> Well,
I'm sorry to hear that. Um I don't really understand. I guess
like the thing is right it seems like you're using it as a justification
uh for your behavior because I spoke in a totally normal volume
and you still crashed out. What did I do that remind you? >> I'm
telling you. I'm telling you that you interrupting me. I realize
that I'm the one interrupting you. >> Yeah. So, no self
awareness. Basically, what happens starting to say something
and when I'm starting to say something is that you're talking
over me and I
talk over me, I just continue to talk. That's what ends up happening.
>> I have to talk over you because you ask me a question
and in the middle of answering you, you start talking and like
obviously I want to get my answer out and like if you're just
like talking over me, I can't get it out. >> You're also
being easily Aiden. You realize Aiden said some really about
me with no reason for it. So like I I'm already coming into this
um this with Io and Resi and all that like the call that was
really [__] >> I called you like crazy Yoko.
Oh no. >> Yoko. Oh no.
>> You realize that you extrapolating that into me having
a relationship and then Io a crazy who had a crush on my boyfriend
who got mad at the fact that I started dating him and made an
issue of it. Right. You calling me Yoko own?
>> I don't know. I don't know if um I still need to see
the the point Aiko is making about this being an issue >> for
her wandering all of her me and >> I was I wasn't doing
I wasn't doing it for her. I was doing it cuz I was you didn't
actually know what was going on. You you I I understand it wasn't
your fault. You wandered into a situation you were used. >> Wait,
I wasn't used. Okay. Based on everything I said >> you
were you were used to launder's ideas. So let's say so let's
say so let's say I'm very I'm a very opinionated person. I already
had opinions about you. I already had I already had opinions
about you going into regardless of what am I saying? I barely
know I don't know why I want you barely know me. Aiden, why would
I ask? >> But I know I know I know enough of you. I know
enough of you to discern your more about than you know about
me. Io has been in the space for longer than me. Okay, then you're
no lure having >> I haven't I I'm sorry. I don't keep up
like every
Wait, do you remember what she did with Edwin? Do you remember
that Edwin saw him? >> I was like gone that year, I think.
>> Okay, so you just don't know. You don't >> No,
no, I don't. But um I don't know who I go is. That's fine. That's
fine. Aiden, I'm sorry. I I assumed that you had some amount
of information was >> The difference is right, you are
right in the sense of I have the same amount of information about
both of you and I've had interactions with the both of you. The
difference is when she's under pressure in her interactions,
she can still based on what I've seen handle herself fine. You
engage in like a total lack of self-control based on a whole
bunch of based
on like minor lines of questioning how emotional you get. >> I
can't believe what you said to me. how emotional you got.
>> Ah, that's what all women sound like.
Thank you, Duckbringer. Yes, >> release the DMs. >> That
was that was I go being reasonable to you. >> Um I probably
>> uh Koser, you missed Destiny coming in here and crashing
out tonight as well. >> Yeah, I didn't see anything unreasonable
about at the time. >> He like joined chat and started typing
in chat talking.
I pulled up uh I just had one question for him. I just needed
to know. Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. Let me go find this.
I just I asked him, "Hey, like with these logs, right, with the
Rose person, is she getting her braces off?" Was this before
or after her parents wouldn't let her fly to Miami to see you?
Which was it before or after?
Did he? Yeah, he did. He He didn't have an answer for me. Oh,
the gift overlay. Oh, were these logs before or after her parents
wouldn't let her come to Miami? I'm probably getting my braces
off in a couple weeks. Oh, exciting. Are you looking forward
to it? This is, by the way, the day after he sent the video pixie
to her. the day after. Kind of a weirdo to be honest with you.
Kind of a weirdo. Yeah. No, he did not. You got him. You got
him pegged correct. >> Well, then you are an absolutely
I don't know what to say. Like I I don't know what to say about
that. If you can if you can see a 40-year-old woman shrieking
and talking like a like a high schooler about some
>> I always find these people like super cringe to go after
each other's ages. I don't know why. It's like 40-year-old woman,
30-year-old man. Um, unless they're not like H.
I don't know. I guess I do, too. I guess I do, too. It's hypocrisy,
but I'm seeing it right now. >> I'm seeing it right now.
What? Why not just block her and move on with your life? She's
clearly always on your mind. >> Cuz you're old, too? Yeah,
but I'm younger than a lot of people. >> I've done that.
>> It's like not a It's not a good insult on its own. Unless
they're acting really, really outside of their age, >> I
have done that. What I'm saying is >> What do you mean?
>> Ignore what she's saying about you. Just move on. >> I
am. >> But you seem like very thin skin. Like typically
most wouldn't be that >> I I don't even care about like
Aiden doing it is fine, right? I feel like it's weird when you're
30 and being like 40-year-old person. It's like dude, what are
you doing?
Why are you Why are you doing that? >> I'm yelling I'm
yelling at you, Aiden, about what is going on right now. I'm
not I don't give a Why do you think what what what do you think?
What What do you think I should be concerned about when it comes
to IEO? Right. >> So, I don't know cuz I don't really care
about me. She's a 40-year-old Spencer who hasn't had
in years. Okay.
about what her opinions of me are. She's mad that I took somebody
that she had a tangental crush on. She somehow decided to only
care about after the fact in seeing it in real time. It's insane.
>> Yes, it is insane. So, it feels like you're taking your
anger towards somebody else out on me, which is like very abuser
like behavior. Taking their like built-up anger to >> abusing
you because you're a target for abuse. You are >> very
What's abusive? She's just talking, >> I'm here to Yes.
I'm I'm abusing you because you're back. You have the ability
to kick me, Aiden. You have every ability to kick me. Don't treat
yourself.
I'm not a little
I'm just telling you. I'm just telling you. I'm just telling
you what you're behaving like. You're behaving like an abuser.
You're taking out buildup anger from other situations on like
the closest the most reachable person in the world. You see,
my opening.
>> Yeah, Cozer, go look at my Twitter. I I had a perfect
Nick tweet today. Why is Essie keeping track of who unfollows
you? Well, America must really suck. Well, to be fair, he he
had the option of stalking me or my social media or hanging out
with not so Eridite or Darius, so obviously he was in my chat
and watching the stream, right? Obviously. Like, come on. Those
are the
>> I'm talking to you. You have every right. Aiden, you
have every right to pick me right now. No, I'm not. This is an
entertaining discussion, but you're so fixated on Eeko. >> Exactly.
So, you're saying
it to you >> No, I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying
you're behaving like an abuser. you're just like not that bright.
Something like gets on my skin. Um, but the thing I have to say
is right when we were having our doxing discussion, IO was so
on your mind. You actually called me here at one point. So, it
feels like you're taking out your anger towards Ieko on me because
you saw me on a stream with Iiko twice. I don't think that's
very healthy. >> No, I'm not. I'm taking out my anger on
you because you are a bad moderator. Most of all, you are somebody
who injects your own opinions into moderations. You claim to
moderate and you have this very um you have this very civil tone
about you where it does seem like you're trying to to speak to
both
>> Oh, was it funny? I didn't see this. I did not see it.
We actually have to struggle over here. You got it easy. I
>> Both sides felt like moderator. >> You're basically
You're basically a Willy Mack. That's what I see you as, Aiden.
You're a very successful Willy and I have a lot of respect for
Willyak. I think he's very intelligent, but I >> Dude,
okay. I did not respect Duckbringer's game. That was really up.
That was insane. That was an insanely up thing to say to Aiden.
I'm not sure that she could have said anything more insulting
to Aiden right there. You're like You're like kind of like Willie
Matt. You're like a Kmart Willy Mac. Holy [__]
That was up. That's how I see >> Okay. Got it. Got it.
I don't remember like asking how you saw me, but it's noted.
It's duly noted. I'll add it to the complaint file. >> I
don't I literally don't care if you disregard me or not. Okay.
Good. Good. Our mogging, I guess. >> Good job. >> Sorry.
What' you say? >> Yeah, exactly. >> Wait, orging
is a thing? I didn't even know that. Oh, I was >> I was
just like talking about dude >> asking like what >> I
I said I put those two words together because it was like a joke
on my part. She's like mogging you or wise. >> You said
just like a question. I don't know. You just like seem to be
like a very like emotional person. I don't know if it's like
very healthy the way you're like releasing. >> Thought
it was aura farming, but >> Well, so are you. I mean, what
do you mean? You're defending your position here constantly.
You're obviously >> I'm not I'm not I'm not emotional about
>> Neither am I. Do I seem emotional right >> Yeah.
Yes. Like two seconds ago, you just like totally lashed out.
It was like crazy. Yes. No, you realize that the ability to yell
over somebody who is speaking over you doesn't >> You sounded
like you were you sounded like you were on You sound like you're
on the verge of tears. >> Do I seem like I'm on the verge
of tears right now? >> It seems like you're trying really
hard to make me think you're not because you realize how insane
you just looked. >> No. What I'm realize what I'm telling
you, Aiden, is that I can I can amp my energy up and down based
off what I think is necessary for a conversation. Somebody's
talking over me, I will necessarily shout over them and speak
over them and just tell them to shut the up because sometimes
people do try to >> dominate conversations that way. >> So,
I'm the one trying to dominate. Got it. So you so it seems like
you had a lot of built-up anger towards IEO. You took it out
here and I guess you had your catharsis. You know, you let all
the rage out. >> I'll tell you that I have no opinions
about Igo. My my if you want like since I've said her name so
much this time, I just want to like I want to get this all out
on on in public. I don't give a I go. I was really happy that
she was friends with Resi. This entire time I have been pushing
them to mend fences and like do everything. That's why it's been
so insane that I has been going around and saying that I'm the
one that is actively like getting between her and resi mending
things because it's actually Res's problem with Ieko that she
can't seem to confront because she's using me as a scapegoat.
And it's really frustrating me because they're friends, right?
They're using me as a scape goat and they're friends. >> Well,
I think wants to call in. >> Would you be down to talk
to her?
>> All right. The line is open. The line is open. We're
waiting on you. Um Yeah. So, I mean I don't know. It sounds like
you Yeah, you sound like very angry. No, she like he she made
Yeah, she made a lot of weird comments about like for example
message that I sent to Perry. I even have screenshots of that.
I said that because he was it was the Marus it was the day the
Marcus stuff dropped and I knew the Connie Inquisition was coming
for Perry's community because I knew they were like the Cunny
>> the Cunny Inquisition.
Nobody
expects it. Okay, nobody ever expects the Cunny Inquisition.
I get banned if I post food shops discard. No. Um you won't get
banned. I might not watch it but you won't get banned. >> Normalization
game. And I was like okay obviously you have a lot of lollycons.
This is going to come back on you. I said haha to him and he
thought I thought that was flirty. It's very >> Got it.
Well, I you're here. You're on the air. What's up? >> Hey,
no. >> I have no idea what's going on. I just got here
to hear that Duck said that I had a crush on Resi and I do not
know what the you were talking Okay, listen. I blocked this girl.
Hold on. No, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me just say I don't
care. I don't care. You are stalker. You are literally stalking
me. I don't I'm not friends with Resi. I will never be friends
with Resi again. And I you are freaking me out >> because
you keep claiming that's me. >> I don't care. I don't care.
I'm not interested. I'm not interested. Sh. Let me just make
this clear, okay? I'm going to make this super clear. I have
blocked you on every platform in every chat and you keep coming
into new chats. You came into my chat yesterday. Your chatters
literally no one. Ladies, ladies, ladies, ladies, ladies, duck,
is that true? Is that true? What just said? Is that true? >> Is
what saying are you coming into Iiko's chats despite her blocking
you? No, I'm not. >> What? You You came into my Kickhat.
You came into my Kick. What do you mean Kickhat? I Do you mean
I followed you on kick and you got mad about it? Is that what
you're saying? >> No, you followed me and then you wrote
>> I followed you on I blocked you on every platform and
then you went on and you followed my kick and you put a duck
emote in like a psycho. Stay away from me for making Okay. Really?
Just a duck emote? Is that all we had go on there? You put a
duck emote in my chat.
Oh, I is not getting tracked. Ah, come on. Really? Oh, I is not
getting tracked on kick chat logs. It's not going to work, is
it? Oh, it's not going to
>> you did.
>> Duck, please. Duck, please.
It turns out that Aiko and Kelly both have the same Achilles
heel, and that is duck reactions. Okay. It's duh. So, you did
comment on I agreed that I followed her on kick. >> No,
you also you also you also posted a chat which you just denied.
Like >> she said something she said something to me. She
said something to me and then I said I >> I didn't say
anything. You posted that. I saw you were in there.
Find the kickod. We can find >> I don't care. My point
is that I have blocked you on every platform. I've hidden you
and we can chat.
You're a [__] stalker freak. Okay. I told you keep
you away from me. I've told him keep you alive
when I posted Chad Logic Jr. in Perry's chat. Did you or did
you not go and message Resi and say control your [__]
[__] >> Uh, no. That's not what I said. I said,
just so you know, this is what she's >> Aiden is Aiden
has no control. Aiden's lost control entirely. >> She's
answering. >> I posted in
everything that happened before the other day when me and Resi
were officially not friends. Everything is irrelevant because
you are. >> If I mute people, they'll leave. >> You
were a [__] to >> I don't care about re my
friendship with resi. My completely platonic friendship, >> but
I'll try it. >> I need
>> Why does he mute? >> Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. If he
if he um or if they want to allege this that I had a crush on
Red Resi, there has to be some proof. There has to be some evidence.
Don't just make that up. Come on. >> Yeah. Actually, >> you're
not flirty about me. You have to slander me and I'm like flirting
with Harry and then I like this. >> Okay. So, can I So,
can I ask a clarifying question? I go, what uh is your like why
do you believe that Duckbrer was flirting with Perry? >> Oh,
because she sends him like weird DMs like she sends him uh DMs.
She's right now. I'll let you talk. She DM'd Perry and deleted
it before he could read it and then he uh mentioned it on stream
and then she DM'd him was like >> you didn't look into
it at all. You didn't ask any >> I don't care. I don't
care.
No one wants you to talk to
not with someone who is
got outed for being
[__] crazy. No one wants you to talk to them. >> It
was the day that Marcus got outed for
lord with some >> the day that Marcus got outed for being
a cunny holic. I thought Marcus I thought the watermelon dog
got his name cleared. Did watermelon dog not get his name cleared?
Didn't they find out that Marcus really didn't do that much wrong?
Or am I crazy? I thought that guy got found, you know, innocent
on all >> Someone who is does not exist to me. Do not exist.
You're speculating about me being flirting with somebody
relationship with this person literally don't give a [__]
You are psychotic. Stay the away from me. You stalker >> Why
are you on
duck? Why are you in? Because you keep you you just admitted
now yourself despite Io blocking you went to her kick chat. Why?
>> No, I didn't go on her kick. >> You You admitted
you commented a duck. >> You put a duck >> in her
kick chat. You just admitted that a few minutes ago. >> No.
No. No. No. No. She blocked me on Discord and I [__]
my kick. >> And did you And yes or no? And yes, did you
comment a duck in her kick shot? >> After she says some
about me. ass.
>> okay. So, you did? >> Only after the >> Yeah,
we can find that. We can find the VOD if you want. I definitely
only commented a >> W. I don't care. It doesn't matter.
You want to talk to me. You are supposed to stay away from me.
You're notable.
You are not a regular acceptable person in the chat alone.
I go I haven't
>> never going to do this again. By the way, this is the
only time I will never talk to again. Ladies, to make this There's
something there's something about this kind of content that just
like goes so hard. Make us go off like let's just do one at a
time. >> I don't know what she has said to you. >> I
don't care what she has told me. >> I care so absolutely
not at all here. I just sent you uh I sent you the time about
me since you have told you I sent you the screenshot. >> Dra,
you've already you've already brought what she said to you. I'm
assuming she said some bad [__] about you. I'm assuming
she said some bad [__] about you cuz she doesn't
like you. Right. With that being said, >> I did not say
bad enough stuff. I was holding back from >> You're an
actual sick human being, JTO. No, I'm not. >> I admit that
she says about me. Even
>> this Sorry, this doesn't have to happen. It's not like
there's a real There's not like a real serious accusation. Like
nobody was looking at this and going, "Oh yeah, like everybody's
going to believe that Io totally had a crush on Resi after this
or something." I don't think that's happening. Is no one else
getting Lav Shell shock? No, nobody's getting Lav Shell shock
cuz everybody here loves Lav. Literally, I am I am a line for
not bringing Lav on the stream, not the other way around. It's
not like people don't want Lav here. People want Lav to come
on and I'm like, "No, no, I don't know. I don't know, man." >> No,
she tells She tells Lesie that we're not having a conversation
about this goes and talks to her, right? >> Stop. Leave
me alone. Leave me alone, you [__] How about you
leave your out of my mouth?
How about you stop talking about my boyfriend and my boyfriend?
How about Aiden, Shut the Excuse me. Should I leave all my DMs
mug so badly?
Get in the [__] >> That's actually true. Aiden
is literally shaking right now. Aiden Duckbringer doesn't even
know that it was Perry who brought out her trauma. Aiden has
like two lesbian moms and all they do is like yell and beat on
each other. And Aiden's like actually trying
violently shaking. >> Excuse me. Stop messing my [__]
middle of my relationship. >> Dude, his his chair is like
>> to get in the middle of my relationship. How about you
stop telling my boyfriend that I ruined his associations when
you're the one that ruined his associations? You got >> everyone
says that about you to him. Literally every single association
have I ruined I ruined everyone. Everyone everyone I'm not saying
I don't I don't like I I conclude. Okay. me for example, every
single person in that
>> why would I just don't understand. Can somebody explain
to me like why duckbrer being content would like ruin resi's
associations at all? Why would I have any difference in of opinion
on like what resi says based on what duckbrer says I don't get
what it doesn't need to connect at all to me. I feel like those
people could be totally independent >> helping resi. Aiden,
you're a slap
[__]
but I don't have like an interest in like he has some like animosity
I think towards him because I've called you a crazy [__]
I don't know if you said something to him. >> Yeah. And
you haven't called. >> His streams got really weird. >> She's
she's actively demonstrating crazy [__] behavior
too because you have cloud to farm from her, right Aiden? >> What
cloud am I farming off Io? She >> Yeah, exactly. She is
a content creator. You have a different stick with her than with
me. I understand. I'm not I'm not pulling the numbers card. I
obviously like I get more than I go on the regular. I'm not trying
to like farm cloud off of her, but you said something and I'm
responding to it. That's how conversation works. But yeah, I'm
not like farming cloud off her. She has like way less viewers
than me and I have no reason to sweep for her if she is crazy.
I just haven't seen any evidence of it. >> you don't know
anything about her, but you're injecting yourself into her arguments
and influencing her.
Wait, really? One thing really [__] fascinating conversation
about
is not the person to go and litigate your drama with. Do you
understand that? Do you do agree that Aiden? Do you agree that
I do agree that is not the Perry? My arguments against you. I'm
bring my arguments against you have been >> No, I had a
disagreement. Aiden had a
independent of Igo. I could not exist and I would still think
you're insane based on how you conduct yourself in conversations.
Duck isn't normal. >> Single [__]
>> basically duck is to resi as mantis is to Tom. Okay.
>> No, I lost debates against a lot of people. I don't
think single debate >> I didn't lose against >> that's
probably yeah that's probably not the best look but let's say
I did and you never got over it >> I've lost debates against
so many people I don't think they're crazy >> you think
it's like >> you have no reason to think that I'm crazy
the only reason that you think I'm crazy also apply to Igo is
what I'm telling you right now >> no so okay I go under
pressure is not here like yelling interrupting every two seconds
when I talk people that she doesn't care about absolutely yells
over >> so when I talk to you when I talk to you >> this
is just true this is absolutely true like Mantis can kind be
content, but she's pretty annoying. She's at least Duck. It doesn't
feel like Duckbrer is trying to be smart. Duckbrer I don't think
Duckbringer thinks she's really intelligent here. I don't know.
Duckbringer is just like disruptive and it's funny. >> You
like can't demonstrate, >> dude. I just realized Duckbringer
and Smug are in the same community. I can't imagine a Duckbringer
versus Smug Bug debate on something.
I had to ask Aaron if that's ever happened. I think they're all
in like the same group chat, the Pon Scum like group chat or
like in that Discord. I feel like a Duckbringer versus Smugma
conversation would just be insane.
That would go so hard. Type of content do these people make?
I don't know what Duckbringer does. I don't know if she really
does content all that much. It's a lot of like commentary like
low lowle commentary or whatever. Oh, duck is ousted from them.
Oh, that's no good. Oh, this this combo broke resi and duck up.
What? What? I know she was on pawn scum. How the did this Okay,
well
>> Enough self-control to like not scream over me. are
going on like crazy tangents. Okay, I have not seen I could do
that. >> I'm interrupted when I'm talking and then I keep
talking. That's what >> You've been the one doing most
of the interrupting. It's a VOD, sweetie. Anyone can rewind.
Do you realize, Aiden, that a lot of people have said a lot of
about me and I haven't been able to respond to a single bit of
it. >> I'm letting you respond. You've I've let you say
everything you wanted. >> That's what I'm doing right now.
I go talked a lot of about me. I haven't said a goddamn thing
about her. >> Um, you literally called in to talk. You
called in to talk about her. >> Oh, I go. Do you know that?
Because you're stalking the chats that I'm in. Is that why you
know it? Not this public stream that you're saying about? >> What?
What?
>> The only reason that you know that I'm talking about
you is because you're >> I literally just arrived. I just
literally arrived. >> I'm here all the time about what
I >> Resi announced his breakup on an announcement stream.
Dude, why?
>> You were writing stuff in Perry's chat back in the day.
All the stuff before when it used to matter. >> That you
leaked my DMs that I said that Perry was super transphobic right
when you went on his platform. You went on the dude that just
a week ago. You're not going to trick me into getting sucked
into talking about this app. We're not talking. We You are a
stalker. You are literally a stalker. I don't trust anything
that you said about anyone else. I don't care what you're saying.
You are insane. You are not a normal level of insane. You are
actually out of control. Can you do her? Wait. And I need to
say something real quick. Please let me say something cuz she's
going to interrupt.
>> Is Duckbringer looking for a community? I feel like
she would fit really well into the VC community in the JC Discord.
Okay. I just think it would I think it's like a natural fit.
We're looking for somebody. Okay. We're looking for somebody
like this. >> In two seconds. Wait, can I say one thing?
Do you not realize you've like done majority of the interruptions,
majority of the talking just to be clear throughout this whole
conversation? Fine. That's fine. I >> I legitimately have
caught only tidbits of what I and Duckbringer are saying going
back and forth. Like they're actually talking over each other
like 50% of the time. It's very funny. Duck versus Shell Bunner
would be very funny. >> I agree with that. I agree. Now,
however I go, listen, you went on the platform of Perry, Purple
Perry Gaming, the guy who made his career off of a logging me
for crying about my abuser, okay? A week prior to you going on
on Perry Street to litigate your supposed intent, you had a friend
that you were trying to litigate
>> through Perry. No, Resi was your friend, >> Okay.
Yeah, that's not your business. Okay, so you want you want
the guy that just a week prior had been analyzing my waistline
so much.
>> Doc Ducker, if that's true, why were you DMing him?
>> I was DMing him laughing at him because I was laughing
as downfall because I had a very I I actually liked Perry as
a person and I was I wanted to be like like friendly with him
for the longest time. That's why I named Chudlo Logic Jr. Like
I'm the person that named Chudlo Logic Jr. >> Okay. I'm
his [__] god. >> Real artist. >> Big
lord dump here. That's awesome. Okay. But I don't I what what
I realized is that he was a logging me. He was going and basically
it was the it was the morning me and said, "Hey, >> I can't
believe." Hold on. It says blah 3xes. I can't get over people
genuinely going purple Perry Gaming. I can't get over the fact
that he managed to rebrand from Pepsi to Perry. Like he was just
Pepsi, but now he's Perry. How the did he get out of Pepsi? I
feel I feel like that's how I like he's seared in my brain is
Pepsi and it's just he's Perry now and Perry fits better but
like I don't know I
>> He said that hey I'm I'm from your stalker and I said
um I don't like that. That's not great. And then I went and I
looked at Perry's stream and his my stalker somebody that for
weeks I had been trying to silence in my community. I had been
trying to not blow up as a crazy person. >> I don't believe
you. >> I don't I don't I didn't
I don't trust you calling anyone a stalker. Okay, you are >> fine.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Just to clarify,
who's your >> Um, it's this guy named Technoplasm Productions.
He's the one that went on Perry. Perry has two VODs about it.
He's the one that said that I had a dummy mommy relationship
with him that was like insane. That like came out of nowhere
when he said that. >> Dude, this is like So, this was somebody
that I was talking to for months who had mental health issues.
They were like confiding in me about those sorts of things. I
was helping them with it and they developed a unhealthy attachment
to me and I for weeks tried to push them away subtly and then
I blocked them and they ended up like spam posting on um like
my friend's forum that he had made. My friend had to shut them
the forum. They ended up contacting a lot of other community
members outside of my community telling me like telling them
all these weird things all these weird conspiracies about how
and this was even before Resi and I were public and they was
like saying basically that Resi and I were in like an abusive
relationship,
So, so where can I
know about I did know I did hear about that. I look into it earlier.
>> I don't care about you. I don't care about you either.
The person then leave me alone.
>> Do you promise? Wait one second. One second. Promise
that you will not
>> Sorry. Aiden, did you think this was your stream? Aiden.
Aiden, do you think this is your stream? Shut the up. Io is >> Boyfriend's
mouth out of your mouth. Okay. Okay. >> If that's if you
can do that, then leave me the alone. I don't care about you.
>> Wait, Dr. McGalif
and my boyfriend's >> Keep me and your my boyfriend's mouth
out of your mouth.
>> She almost said name. She almost said keep your mouth.
Keep your my boyfriend's mouth out of your name. Okay. Keep it
out. >> That's what she's saying. >> Well, if you
can do that. >> She did say mouth. She said she realized
at the end she was going to say n and then she was like, "Ah,
mouth. I know I up." Ah, >> I'm going to have to sound
clip that for later. That was awesome. Someone clipped that for
me. >> Drucker, just to be clear, critical
critical misspeak. Critical. >> This is like a commentary
drama space. So like nobody's an obligation to stop talking about
anybody else. But while we're here, u my question is when he
was stalking you and accusing you of By the way, if I'm not even
going to push I'm not even >> He says, "I'm not sure I
go." >> Can we not Can we not reach out? I'm not Okay.
Okay. So I'm not Guys, guys, >> hold on. Can you please
stop? She also went and commented on an unrelated VOD like uh
you got by Perry. I hope it was worth it or I hope you got
talking to me. I am this no contact. You want to talk about me
on your platform. >> Ladies, ladies, ladies. So my question
about me, do not contact me on my platforms or in my DMs. Okay,
>> that's a fair request. Will you agree with that duck
bringer? Just have to contact her. >> Yeah, that's fine.
I haven't been doing >> Aiden's totally in control now.
He got a question answered. He's totally in control. He's totally
back in the driver's seat. Aiden is in control. Patriots are
in control. Guys, >> [__] chat, you psycho.
>> You admitted that already. >> You DM'd me or you
chatted at me in >> Do you think was actively talking about
me in chat? Do you think that's not a problem akin to me going
into >> I was not talking about you was my music
>> So, okay. >> It was my music stream. >> You
were you were the same the same stream that I followed you in.
You talked about me and all
that. Leave me alone. Leave me alone. That was my really >> You
are actually very disturbing. Will you Can you agree to not contact
me? >> Sad lonely spinster if you die alone. Just Okay,
great. Can you just not contact me anymore? Do I >> not
really? Because your personality is kind of kind of going to
assure that. So, it's whatever. >> So, I don't think that
you like necessarily have have an obligation uh to not in her
chat, but I feel like if you're going to like sit here and accuse
her of stalking you, I think you should probably like you should
probably not be going stalking her. >> Yeah. So, I think
I wasn't here for this. Aiden. Um, Aiden, if she insane, I don't
care. Do you think that I have no obligation to go with >> Listen,
I will never talk about her because Wait a minute. Stop. Shut
that [__] down. Okay. Unless you
by the way, I go I like how you have
Leave me alone. Crazy. I don't care. Leave me alone. Don't bring
her. Don't bring her. If if you if she talks about you, a way
you can respond is like when you stream yourself, right? You
can talk about on stream. You could talk about chat. No, I can't
do that because Sunday
went into President Sunday specifically went into Res's stream
and said, "This is the drama. This is the end." I was going to
say something on my stream on Friday, but you're doing this now
because Sunday went >> Yeah. I go, "You're the one that's
causing this." >> No, you did bring her up. >> You
were already talking about me apparently for a long time. I have
no idea what you were even saying. You were talking about me.
>> I go I go this dark. >> I appeared in your stream.
You would have a lot more ducker interventions. Okay. cuz you
you talk about me a lot.
I will not talk about you. I will I will I will tell people to
stop talking about you. Okay. Contact me. Okay. Just don't >> Wait.
Okay. I'm muting both of you real quick. Please don't leave.
So, real quick, I'm not This is impersonal. I'm going to do this
one at a time. So, Duckbringer, will you agree hereby going forward
to not reach out to Aiko directly through her chat? >> He
had to mute. He had to mute to gain control. To regain control,
he had to mute them. >> Oh, boy. >> Or servers or
anything else going forward. Duck, >> I have already agreed.
Yes,
I have already and I will continue to do that. Now, when it comes
to maybe following to see her content, maybe I've done that before,
but I will not even do that when it comes >> Well, that's
not going to matter cuz we have no way of knowing that. It's
just like probably going to be like public uh >> contact
the following like Yeah. If somebody says if if it says that
I'm following and she says something about it and then like I
posted, >> don't keep don't follow and unfollow me. I blocked
you. I'm like, are you going to make new accounts just to follow
me? >> Okay, I go I go I go to be fair. To be fair, there's
nothing you can do to prevent that. That's probably going to
happen. But my my question psychotic. >> It is. It is,
but that's not really like something like she's allowed to be
psychotic in that way. My question then would be, you've agreed,
you've agreed, I don't think you have to do this, psycho, but
you've agreed to stop talking about her. >> I'm going to,
you know, if she does something crazy and I'm not going to like
ban her name in general, but I'm going to trap myself in this
hole.
I'm not going I'm not going
>> I just did. Sorry, keep going. >> I'm not going
to uh marry myself to that. I will not casually talk about her,
but I'm not going to put my any kind of uh barriers on what I
do regarding this person.
As far as like some [__] I go, I'm going to say stupid
[__] >> So, I go see you doing some stupid
[__] I point out that you're doing some
that isn't to me or on my platform. >> So, I go >> not
to me. Not in my servers, not in my >> How do you think
about Lily Lucifer? >> I don't care. I don't care. Yeah.
Anything that anyone says about you, that's their that's their
uh >> And you don't care about Wait, why? >> I don't
I'm not going to talk about my >> I don't care about what
your chatter
is supposed to wait. Why are you supposed to moderate what her
chatters are saying about you? Unless they're like doxing >> It's
not It's not that they're doxing me. It's that when you have
a chatter that's intentionally going into other people's chats
to start and to like clip people, you should speak to that chatter
>> That's part of being in the drama series. No obligation
to talk to her about that. >> It's not working. >> I'm
not saying she has to. I'm saying if she cares about her friendship,
she could probably
I wouldn't do that. I Here's something that's extremely toxic.
You are correct when you say that I am old. I am
way too old for this to be manipulated by people into like, oh,
you should really go through all your things if you want to say
your friendship. I'm not going to be I am not going to be manipulated
and like do all this extra emotional work and labor for someone
that is toxic. And maybe you can't see that it's because you
are toxic. But this is the thing. I'm not having any part of
like that's why I don't with you since day one because I saw
you were this kind of person.
>> I don't know what the >> What does that have to
do anyway? >> Well, when someone says I'm >> okay.
I I got the appropriate thing working again, guys. Yes. Yes,
it works. All right.
>> Continue. Let's continue. >> So, like when somebody
says you're right, when you're having >> I don't require
validation, but you can get validated, right? Also this doesn't
matter.
You're having an interpersonal dispute from your friend. Do you
realize people in the community not necessarily
the people around you
take on right >> so
drama that you had with resi resi is a good person. You did not
have to have this drama with him. I did not have this drama with
him. Not your business drama. I don't I don't have any business
>> I'm not friend. I will never You guys could break up
today and I would never be friends with Resi for the rest of
my Don't care. Totally fine. I have great friends who are there
for me and who support me. >> Wait, why is that? Why does
that matter? Wait, why does that matter, duck? just not friends
with like the person like you all of these years against the
associations that you had in Twitch poll and the adjacent community
offended you. >> Was it just President Sunday or was it
your business your crazy parasocial ideas of what internet creative
friendships are like
ducker she has said she has no interest in being friends with
resi again. They're not going to be friends again. So what why
are you like concerned? >> That's fine. What I'm concerned
about is that when when I go originally blocked me, I told her,
"Hey, it's crazy that I'm the one telling you that if you go
on Perry, he's just going to >> I'm like for about 90 seconds
just free booting. This will be her back." >> Inflame more
and more and more. If you care about resi if you're friends with
resi, you should not go on Perry to litigate these things. And
she blocked me because I called her
because you're crazy. >> Wait, wait, wait. Duckbrer. Duckbrer.
Do you not realize it's like a bit of like special treatment
in this community to start like asking people not to call into
other people's streams and like and like ask them not to talk
about certain people, not to say certain things? >> I understand.
I understand what I was saying is that like you understand that
when I tell somebody not to go Harry I'm speaking from a place
of like experience, right? Like I'm saying that Harry is a troll
and if you go on his stream, you're not going to get like a fair
shake, right? So I go to charge about the situation
like in my in my timeline of friendships, this is barely a blip.
Okay, your idea of toxic toxic relationships, friendships, whatever
like that, that is a very narrow world. It is a narrow, miserable
world where you are just controlling each other and and just
dealing with each other's emotions and and having a bunch of
feelings, but it doesn't actually go >> Apparently res
more about your friendship than you did. And that's
why wait, hold on. Io is a grown woman. Why does anybody need
to care about her friendships, what she's doing, etc., et like
who cares? She doesn't want you to >> Because she's Yeah,
that's fine. And that's what I understand is that she's acting
like a high schooler. And yeah, I have to I have to understand
that's her mistakes to make. She's going to lose the associations
she had. That's why she lost Resi as a friend. And that's too
>> Well, you keep saying that. You keep saying that. What
is going to cause her to lose an association with anybody besides
Resi?
>> Nothing. That's the thing is that >> so nothing
she's doing is going to cause she's been telling Resi that that
because of me Resi is going to lose associations. She's been
acting everyone says that about you. >> Yes. Yeah, I said
that about you. I didn't even hear
said that about you. >> Wait, what association? Dickers
doesn't >> You are you're a total nightmare to deal with.
And if Resi's going to like defend your like insanity, like it's
going to be hard to associate. >> You don't like me. Resi
doesn't have to defend my insanity. That's the thing is that
Resi never has to defend my insanity. I don't ask him to defend
my >> He doesn't he doesn't by virtue of him being your
boyfriend. But virtue of him being your boyfriend is talking
over
me. Aiden, you're currently talking over me. >> Sorry,
I'm done speaking now. >> I can't even do it, dude. >> Okay,
so I have my own associations and my own platform, right? And
if people want to tie Resi and I together as a single entity,
and they want to say that whatever resi does is clearly influenced
by me, they can do that. That is very disingenuous to Resi. That
is very unfair to Resi because he's somebody who is a very opinionated
person and so am I. The fact that we decided to get together,
shut the [__] The fact that he and I decided to get
together, okay, means that we understand that we are. >> Are
you proud of yourself in your career? Do you feel fulfilled?
Does this make you happy? >> Yes. I love the fact that
I can go and follow like something that does make me feel fulfilled
like uh like politics and try to form opinions on it, debate
it with other people that does make me feel happy and then I
can go and do this as well. I love that I have a platform where
I can do both. I get to choose whatever makes me feel happy on
that day. That is awesome. It's great. are going to have like
conflicts with that, right? So, >> wow. So cool. >> awesome.
So deep mature. >> Yeah. I go, I wonder why your 10 year
relationship failed. >> Okay. I've heard Well, 10 years
is like a one type of relationship doesn't always work out. It
happens. Um but I uh >> I'm sure her chat didn't have any
influence on
>> why would her chat >> You think my 10year relationship
was influenced by her realize how her voice just got really high
pitched, right? >> Well, yeah, because she's conveying
surprise cuz that statement is obviously catching off guard.
She doesn't know what we're talking about. The first 5 years
was before I was even on >> Why did I just on stream? Uh,
no. I don't think this is like This is empty. Yeah. Ooh, but
the closest I've ever gotten to a voice crack on stream. This
is like empty,
but uh it's not like it's not the worst. This is like probably
not fulfilling, but a lot of the other content does feel fulfilling.
I do feel like quite at home doing it. So,
>> YouTube or Twitch. >> Why did you none of your
business? >> Yeah, exactly. my business. You don't have
to do anything about it. >> Yeah. Why would >> obviously
you're the one that me and Resi in the very beginning, we tried
to have an intervention for you to stop giving so much information
about yourself and you still have not figured it out. >> I
go, I'm aware that your grandma is dead. I'm aware where you
live and what your profession is. I'm aware of a whole bunch
of about >> You definitely don't sound like a stalker.
You definitely don't sound like a stalker with that one. >> I'm
sorry. She cried about her grandma being that dead. She cried
about it.
>> What about what you >> Yeah. You know where she
>> Dude, what? How is that [__] talking? This
dumb cried about her grandma dying. What a stupid [__]
>> Liv, what are you talking about? >> Yeah. Wait,
I gave my address to
>> Didn't I give my address to Resi? >> Yeah, you
did. You probably shouldn't have, [__]
what? What?
What? Okay, definitely not psychotic at all. You probably shouldn't
have, Dude.
That that exact cadence just made me think of the the nick.
Abe, I control your address. Your address, my choice.
>> Resi, wait. Wait. Resi gave >> Holy laugh there.
>> Address to
>> Didn't I give my address to Resi? >> Yeah, you
did. You probably shouldn't have been. >> You wait. Resi.
Wait. Wait. Resi gave you Iiko's out. >> Okay, that's psychotic.
Totally disavowed. but also incredibly funny. So hard to That
really sucks.
>> No, I don't have >> I assume Resi would never
give Duckbringer the address, so it's probably fine. >> I
go's address at all. I only know where she lives based off things
that she >> No, that's not true. I did give my address
to Resi.
>> And he didn't say it to me. Prove it. >> You literally
just said it. >> What do you mean? >> This is really
serious. You don't come here with doxing threat. It It is kind
of psychotic for her to say that. I I feel like there's just
no reason to go to this.
going to talk to you. I'm going to dox you. I'm going to dox
you.
>> What the [__]
I'm going to dox you.
Dude, what?
What the hell? What is happening?
>> I would consider a restraining order. I go a little
bit crazy. Okay, I'll be asking Resi for your information. >> Please
do it. >> I will be. Yeah. >> Okay. She left. Um
Yeah. I don't know what the whole deal is with that. Uh >> that
is insane because he had this goal all like all the whole beginning
of the year was a goal to come uh to fix his car so he could
come and take me to the beach and do a stream on the beach. Okay.
That's why I gave him my address. >> Got it. Got it. >> So
my information isn't even safe with Resi because of his psychotic
freak >> Well, no. I feel like the Also, I feel like that
would have been spooky for Resi to hear to hear Duckbringer kind
of threaten. I go like that. I feel like there's no way Resi
would have given that information away. There's just no need
for for Duckbringer to have it, >> She may she may have
been giving empty threats, but I understand why you might think
that's real. I don't >> She's insane. >> Yeah. I
don't know about the nature of your relationship. >> Well,
he has that information. So, uh >> I don't know. I listen,
I know guys will do a lot for for the for the women they love.
I don't know for I don't know Resi too well, you know, way better
than me. I don't know if he'd go that far. Uh >> well,
for the record, I hold Resi fully responsible for this. >> Whatever
comes of this, I hold him 100% responsible. And whatever happens
is on his head. >> Well, yeah, but to be fair, she might
be bluffing and res might not have gotten your address. >> Doesn't
matter. I'm going from whatever happens. Okay. Whatever comes
of this. >> I That kind of actually ratt
>> is on him. Okay. He can say what he wants to say. I
would like him to publicly say, >> "Hi, I just wanted to
say I go real quick." The only reason the beach trip was ever
a thing was >> ducking Ed Dickers. What? Also, Aiden, what
the is this layout? I don't even want to hang out with me.
Fix his car so that we could go around traveling. The beach trip
with you was an afterthought. Just saying. >> Okay. So,
are you saying that he was shilling? He was shilling. He was
just using me to chill >> to fix his car. He was using
you to chill. Yes. He never actually wanted to hang out with
you. The intention was to hang out with me. You weren't. >> All right.
This is like,
dude, this is weird levels of petty >> afterthought. I'm
the one that reminded him to tell you there was going to be a
plus one. And the only reason that he said, "Hey, there might
be joining us was because of me." >> Dickers, what do you
want to I don't know how the I don't know how the Duckbringer
can come on here and say that what Aiko is ruining her relationship
with Resi and condemn her for that when Duckbringer is a thorn
in the side of every relationship that Resi has with anyone.
I don't know why she's trying to litigate Resir's issues on streams
or in chat with other people in the most otic way. >> Do
you think I should do you think >> Trust the plan? I'll
kick him. I'll take >> You just need to stop talking about
resi's personal issues cuz right now
this plan about this trip that they planned. What the does that
achieve? >> She's the one that brought it up. >> I
do feel like um like the level of stuff you shouldn't be doing
is coming in and going like um like there's a certain level of
thing you could litigate like people's issues on the internet,
but then going like actually privately resi really hates you.
That's probably something you shouldn't do. That's that's rough.
>> All right. Well, while I have you here, Dickers, I'm
not looking for a second commentator to comment on what's going
on, but I want I think you'd be relevant to have here because
you're one of the people uh that has said that uh that has said
that uh Duckbrer is like a weight on resi and she seemingly takes
issue
>> uh doesn't have to be >> around his neck. I didn't
>> I'd say I don't know. That's Res's decision to make.
You know, if if Resi, you know, and it seems like he did, but
if she was like, you know, having some effect in a way that Resi
didn't like, then that's just Res's decision to make. >> Understand
that entirely. I was wondering why. Aside from Igo, I don't really
have problems with anybody in commentary, Dickers. I've had issues
with you. I have problems with you. >> Yes. Okay. So, yes,
you do have issues with other people in commentary to be >> I
care more about your opinion, Dickers, than I go. >> Right.
So, >> right. Well, I think that you're doing like weirdly
like jealous cope to be >> You empathize with that? No.
When does Cherry go on like a stream and talk about how I feel
about things or other people? I don't empathize with this at
all. It's like not close. >> I feel like a lot of your
anger and animosity, this might be why you think that you have
like issues with Iiko in particular, is a lot of your like jealous
animosity has like been towards Io because she's got a very long
pre-existing relationship with Resi for like a long time, right?
I have I have no I have no jealousy towards Io this entire time
privately. I can send you so many >> res female friends
and she just happens to be the main target of
that was the one that had animosity towards me first of all not
the other way around. I think Io has actually been incredibly
restrained. Io is a psycho. I love sheer with the hate, but she's
been able to restrain herself for like months. >> This
entire time this entire time, do you think this entire time I've
been saying I have no problem with you being friends with Iiko,
even if she dislikes me? Like, do you think that has nothing
to do with >> No. No. It's got no effect. Especially if
you're going to start to start to like stir up drama between
her and Resi.
>> I want I got you in her dickers because I wanted to
ask you. Dude, I have to go back and see Aiden's face when he
did
>> I got you in here, dickers, because I wanted to ask
you if you can list. I'm sorry. I just I can't I can't take anymore.
I want you to list
somebody. I want you to list in three in >> I'm going to
st I'm going to start stalking somebody. >> Three reasons
why you think that Duckbringer is a weight on resi. That's all
I want you in here for right now. Can you give me three reasons?
>> Yeah. Um, I think number one is just going to be the
fact that Dougbringer is constantly litigating Resir's issues
that he might have with other people, but she's going ahead and
being a schizo barbarian in calls with people uh in people's
chats and just all around. >> Second of all, >> can
you give examples of that, Dick? >> Wait, let him get to
him. >> That's that that's a that's a big claim.
>> I've been I've been pigeonhold into giving three. I'm
very sorry. I'm like a I'm not a genie right now. Um, the second
one is generally being skitso.
And the third one is whenever people speak to Res about you,
you schizo DM them afterwards with copy pasted DMs. >> Yeah,
you did that to me. You did that to me. Okay, but before I get
rid of copy paste, I can I can actually prove that I didn't copype
paste DMs. I actually sent every >> Okay. So, so sorry.
So, sorry. You wrote Sorry, you wrote original DMs. >> It's
just me. Or does Dickers do the deepening voice thing that President
Sunday does? Uh, does President Sunday do something to bass boost?
I've never gotten that impression. >> You wrote original
DMs. Got it. But Dickers radio next time. >> You guys think
Sunday? I don't think Sunday base boosts. There's something about
like it's just like a natural tenor. I think >> I want
to call into your stream. You pick the [__] up. All
right. Sorry ladies. Now we're here. Um I just uh you know I
think that there is I think that you two are never going to like
each other. I doesn't want to be friends with Resi again. So
I don't understand what your problem is. >> That's fine.
I have no problem with it as long as she doesn't talk about my
relationship and talk about Resi as if he doesn't have agency
to make his own decisions. And >> we're still like 30.
Guys, donate some subs. If you like the content, donate some
subs. It's a bad TTS message. Okay, we are out of time on the
stream, but I kind of have committed to finishing. So, >> to
control his own relationship. That's what I disliked. I've Wait,
let me just finish. I've disliked the save resi. I've disliked
the duck is in his ear, worm tonging him sort of thing because
it all works to minimize his agency, which really bothers me.
>> So, you're not in his ear at all. >> That's what
people think. >> That's just what people think. >> Just
to be clear, anybody who's like in a relationship where like
the partner is like doesn't like friends of the other partner,
there's probably going to be a bit of talking about that behind
the >> But here's the problem is that I like I go. I've
always liked. >> That is not true. Come on. >> Well,
if you haven't enjoyed, then type a three in the chat to receive
a oneweek timeout. Come on. Be honest with me. I guarantee you
>> you literally unprompted came on here trying to argue
she's a crazy >> You can find me because she has been a
crazy [__] to me in spite of me trying to reach out.
>> So, why are you arguing that you like >> No, what
I've been doing is I've been trying to reach out to her to say,
"Listen, I've never had a problem with you. You are making me
the problem in the situation. You are making me the the point
of of of contention here when I am actually not able to speak
for myself because I blocked me able to speak. >> Just
to be clear, you can speak for yourself. I I platformed you here
tonight. You're allowed to. You have a stream you can talk on.
>> You not towards Io. Io doesn't listen to >> Because
she doesn't want because she doesn't want to. Yes. Because she
doesn't want to talk. She made it clear. Dude, there's no way.
There's no way. You go. Shouldn't give your address to my boyfriend.
I'mma dox you. And you come back. You're like, I doesn't listen
to me. I never listens to me. Dude, what?
>> She's made she's made >> that was that was the
point where I'd be like, "Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no." >> But
she does not want to speak to you directly anymore. And that's
her choice. >> What sucks is that she's using this division
to like to instigate to to exacerbate this issue between her
and Resi. She has >> There is no Shut the up. She has used
me as as >> do the tone switch,
>> dude. What >> between her and Resi? She has >> there
is >> She's doing this to litigate this thing between me
and Resi. >> Shut up. Shut the up. Shut the up. She has
used me as as a scapegoat to say that I am worm tonging resi
that every animosity that Resi has towards her is coming from
me when that's
opposite. It's been about I've been telling Resi exclusively
Io. I've been telling I was the reason that he talked to you.
I was the reason he told you like
by the way. Can you just make it like >> with you? I go.
I like I go. I think she's like a life cleric. I think she she
tells people to take their meds. That's good. It's so
meds at noon every day. I have no problem with you. >> Someone
get me Someone get me the Chudlogic lithium clip now. Okay. I
need it right now. Chudlogic is like a life >> Are you
fighting with my boyfriend who thought of you as a friend? He
cared about you. I go >> I'm actually sad right now. I'm
actually sad that I feel like continuing this animosity towards
a person that has no actual problem with her. It's all about
me and I'm a bad person. >> No, it's not you. It's not
your fault. >> You're using me. Exactly. It's not my fault.
It's not your fault. Please say that. It's not my fault. Your
friendship with Rey ended. Okay.
>> Oh, it actually worked, too. >> Aiden. Aiden,
let me just talk to D. Okay. It's not your fault. Okay. It's
not your fault. I thought a lot more was your fault uh before,
but now I've thought about it more and I really think >> I'm
crying. I am crying. I'm being vulnerable right now. You're right.
I go I'm crying. Aiden, you get content of me crying because
I'm so sad because President does legitimately seem beat up about
this. Okay. He seems legitimately sad that he thought that he
trusted somebody and he couldn't. He felt >> Dude, I got
p I's like actually
going to try to take care of her now. That's >> pretty
nuts. I like totally ready to take care of this person. You can
hear it in the voice. >> Out of control in the situation.
He felt like he couldn't talk to you without you going public
with everything. That's what I was trying to tell you originally.
What I was trying to tell you originally, Io, is that you don't
go on Perry unless you want to get farmed. And that's all I'm
saying. I'm sorry that I called you. I did not know that you
were OCD, okay? If I had known you were OCD, I would have never
said anything offensive to you because I know it's hard for you
to come back from that. Okay? I'm sorry. >> Okay. Well,
listen. We've all gotten very vulnerable. We've all gotten very
lots of tears have been shed. >> Aiden's like for this.
He's like, "Oh god, people got emotional. Get them out. Get them
out. Get them out. Emotions.
Get them out." >> But it is clear would like to just like
cease all communication with you. Um, >> and that's fine.
I'm okay with that. Like I said, I just felt bad. I feel bad
that Resi lost associations over this because it's felt like
I haven't had a single voice in this to say like, "Hey, yeah,
I'm in a relationship with this person. Yeah, I'm a Yeah, like
I I have opinions, but like why does that have to be his problem
specific?" >> No, you're right. You're right. Okay. You're
right. And I I do I I I didn't understand for a while. Now I
have like more of a an understanding of what I think maybe went
on that was more directly with Resi and me. I don't I don't I
don't know. >> She's crime.
>> She's trying to manipulate. You're giving it to >> Well,
I'm I'm just listening, >> dude. No way. Hold on. She's
crying.
>> Hold on. >> She's crying.
>> I feel like Aiden is trembling right now. Look at how
trembly that cup is. >> I'm sorry. That was up. That was
>> She's trying to manipulate. >> She's trying to
manipulate. You're giving it to >> Well, I'm I'm just Listen,
it's fine. I'll go with >> Maybe not. Maybe not. Maybe
it was okay. Not Not bad. Not bad. >> I thought I thought
he has I thought he was trembling, but it's okay. It's okay.
>> Yeah, you need He tried to He did He did try to >> I'm
just >> He tried to do the Queenman thing.
>> She's trying to manipulate your normal normal white
mug. It doesn't have the aura of the tiny little espresso jar
in a tiny little hand. Okay. It's not got the evil aura. Okay.
Queen would have just been like trying to manipulate you right
now. Then he would have taken a little sip. Yep. Little espresso
cup. Tiny little espresso cup in a tiny >> I'm just Listen,
it's fine. I'll go with it. I'll go with it. It's okay. It's
okay. What I'm What I'm saying is it is not you. It's not your
fault that Resi has behaved and said the things that he said
and thrown snipes at me over time. That's not your fault. These
are his choices. So that is based on that. Okay, you let's say
all of that was happening without you existing whatsoever. Just
>> that kind of was a full sip right there. That's that's
crazy. >> Doing those things that he did is enough for
me to not be friends with him ever again. So, it's not your fault.
>> Completely agree with that. I completely agree with
that and I understand. And if you and Resi had like your own
personal it was only because I was tied up with it that I invested
now and I don't want to stream all the rest of this but I have
to >> felt like it it made me upset because like I said
he seemed to care about you. you know, he actually was interested
in like meeting you and going to the beach and and I'm the one
that told him like, "Hey, make sure that she knows that I'm going
to be there so she's not weirded out by it, you know, cuz like
I'm not I'm a nobody, you know." >> Well, Dr. Speaker,
I can't speak for Io, but in regards to like his contact with
everyone else, the breaking off, it is your fault. >> That's
fine. If he understands that and he has chose to be with me over
associations, he might lose. He knew that when we first got together,
I said early on before we even went public, hey, I know that
I'm a spur and that associating with me is going to be bad for
you. Maybe we shouldn't be public. And you know what? It wasn't
really our choice. It was Perry and my stalker that decided to
make it public. Okay. Okay. >> And yeah, it sucked. I didn't
have a choice over any of that. And I know I'm crying. I know
I make myself look embarrassed. Whatever. >> But like that's
all I want to say to you is that I liked you. Like when you and
Resi originally confronted me on everything that I said to you,
>> I don't really care >> was genuine. When I was
viewing your stream that day where I chatted with you and I I
I stupidly went on my my other account, my main account, and
I decided to evade a ban. Yeah. Like that was all me just being
your chatter because I like your content. I like your vibe. I
think it's good. And it's really bothered me this whole drama
between you two. That's so arbitrary. >> Nobody believes
just nobody believes you like her. You're saying this to be manipulative
cuz you want you want to be >> Come on, Aiden. Listen,
this is what I mean about you being a moderator. You're not helping
right now. >> I I don't know what you're doing. I'm starting
my own opinion. I disagree. >> that's fine. >> Well,
I mean, to be fair, >> you had to gain from this. I had
to gain from crying again on >> You want You want I got
to stop speaking about you negatively. >> No, I don't care.
All I had to do was stop looking at her streams and she was >> You
were clearly unable to do that. She blocked you and you still
went on her kick stream >> because she still it still this
whole situation still upsets a lot of people that I know. It
still were part of my community. This is a very stupid drama
that has been exacerbated by trolls like Perry, people who have
farmed me since the beginning of their career. >> Then
stop giving them stuff to farm. >> I'm not. And that's
originally why I got mad at IGO and why I called her and why
I felt bad and wanted to apologize is because it was really my
anger towards myself that I projected onto her when I said why
would you go on to Paris to litigate something you apparently
care about. That's all I was saying. And I understand that it
came off really rude if I go and you don't know me I go and I'm
sorry that I came off rude. >> Do you just follow people?
>> Is this true that like >> yeah just do everything
I want.
I swear. >> Thank you. I would be very happy if you please
don't DM me. Please don't come into any chat. Please don't comment
on any platform. Don't go into any servers at I don't I don't
I don't and if you >> no you don't like you will you won't
cuz you were
what happened with when I went on your kick when I went on your
kick and then like I think I wanted to post like a dance emoji
or something >> you admit to doing it why you did it doesn't
matter okay you did it maybe just like don't do that >> I'm
saying is I go I won't do that I won't follow I won't interact
with any of your stuff it upsets you and all I ask for you as
well is that if your chatters are specul speculating about resi
only doing things because of my influence please know enough
about your friend to say resi is an opinionated
>> he's not my friend but also I will say we're not talking
about that from now on when they talk about resi and ducks relationship.
What I'm going to do as of now, I could change my policy later
depending on how things go. But for right now, you agree to not
talk to me and I will anytime someone's like resi and duck, I
will cut that out. If someone has a criticism for resi specifically,
you don't have to >> if they say resi and duck for now.
Okay. But if you if you start poking around, if I see people
in my discord, >> ever meddling. Yeah. You have every reason
to say, "Hey, Duck is meddling. She's in I like >> But
I don't ever want to have to do >> She cracks up the tears.
You're falling for it. I just I need to say that." >> No,
I just really want her to leave me alone and I'm scared of her
kind of. >> I feel the same way about a big influence.
I I feel like I don't know if it's just to manipulate here. I
I don't know if I'd say that, but it is um Aiko is a re immediately
ready to take care of this person instead of like kind of being
as mad as she should have been, which is very mad. >> She
doesn't want I just don't want you. You're threatening to dox
me. >> Yeah, you did. >> No, I go I'm not actually
what I said. >> How do I know? I don't know. I don't
>> I don't know apparently. So, I don't know anything.
>> I want you to know fully that I never I don't have any
information about you. I'm not even going to like like say what
vague information I might know based off like things that I >> well
you alluded to it where he where he and I wanted to go like what
I said. >> No, she was I I joked about that cuz she was
saying that I knew her doc based off something I said and I was
I was laughing about it. I'm going to
get the feeling she was laughing or >> I don't know where
I live. >> She sounded like straight up malicious. >> Knew
where she lives. >> I don't I don't know that I said I
know where she lives. >> You literally just said that.
See, you know what? I was trying to go along with this, but it's
like it's just so bad. I go I know. I go I know the state that
you live in. That's all. Like I don't know how I know that. I
don't know if I learned that from res. >> Everyone knows
that we were going to go to the Jersey Shore. >> Yeah,
that's what I know. >> Everyone knows that. >> Yeah,
but I'm telling you not. I'm >> So why are you saying I
don't even live >> You want her to believe you had her
address? You want her to believe you had her address? >> I
didn't want her to believe that. I laughed about it when she
>> Oh, wait, wait, wait. Perry was here. Somebody asked
how Perry knew I don't know if Perry's still here. Somebody asked
how Perry knew that Duckbringer had been abused. And I said,
"Man, I bet you Perry has the most insane
answer to that question." So, let's see. I'll see. >> You
didn't deny that. You said you were >> How was that ridiculous?
>> I don't actually. No, because you were accusing do you
were accusing Resi of doxing you and I was laughing about it
because I had only ever said that I knew the state that you lived
in. >> Well, yes. To be clear, I I did I could believe
that resi potentially gave her address to you and you didn't
shut that down. You entertained it and you didn't just say you
know what state she lives in. You said you knew where she lives
and when we given an opportunity to >> I agree that I laughed
my ass off about that, but I want you guys to understand that
I laughed about that because it's so ridiculous. Come on. Nobody
believes this. Listen. I go I go. Do you live near Kate May?
That's where I want to go. I want to go to Kate May. >> Who
cares? You don't live near. >> No. I I was never going
to Kate May. So, I don't know what you're talking about. >> I
want to talk over.
>> Sorry. I keep >> That's all. So, so whatever I
said before, if I laughed about it, it was because it was such
a ridiculous accusation that I was cracking up about it. I'm
sorry if that seemed like like I I understand like the concern
about doxing when you like released PI to somebody. That's also
kind of like why resi deleted all of his DMs with you, right?
Cuz he >> That's not why. >> That's That's total
Come on. >> That is total.
He hasn't given me any information that I could do anything with
anyway. >> Even when he might think that he might he might
think that he might not think that. I don't know what reason
he had for it, but I just
gave the reason. You just gave the reason. >> Oh my god.
Okay. Do you happen to be on any substances? >> No. Are
you? >> Yes. Weed. But you sound like you might be on something
extra. >> No, I'm not on anything. I go. >> You just
are kind of forgetting what you're saying. >> Oh, okay.
>> It's It's not I realize now it's not like incompetence.
It's like totally >> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Let's see here.
Perry actually answered me. They said they had an abusive ex
in our DMs after our first combo and then they edited out abusive.
Our first combo was about how they weren't being respectful to
me during our convo and they treated me very treated me like
a dancing monkey. Very evil stuff. That's like a perpetual complaint
for you though, Perry. You said Duckbringer was treating you
like that. I've heard you complain that Queenman treats you like
that. Oh, I should clarify. They compared me to their abusive
acts in DMs. That's why they brought it up. I see.
>> They're very manipulative individual. >> You see
why you don't want to talk? Yes. Yes. Were you saying duck? >> You
understand? I go, you understand when you tell me like when I
say like, "Oh, I wanted to go on the beach trip with you." And
then I started talking about that and then you guys tried to
speculate that Resi had doxed you to me. That's kind of how that
happened, right? >> That's not how that happened. >> I
gave it was literally like I forget what Duckbringer said, but
I was like, "Yeah, I gave my address to Resi." And I Duckbrer
was like, "Shouldn't have done that, you stupid [__]
I'mma dox you." Like,
>> that's how I perceived it. That's how I perceived it.
I might be wrong. I might be wrong. The reason I laugh at pretending
that that was an auto that was a ridiculous jump of logic where
I laugh at it. Okay. >> You weren't you weren't just laughing.
You weren't just laughing at it. You didn't deny it and then
you like outright played into it. Just be clear. >> Yes.
You said yes. I Yeah.
>> Shouldn't have trusted him. >> I'm just saying
I know where you live. Unprompt the I know where you live part
was totally unprompted. There was nothing happening in the conversation.
>> You realize that that's me. Do you realize, Aiden, that's
me saying like, "Haha, you're being [__] ridiculous.
Yeah, I know where you live." Yeah. I don't really know where
I >> That's not the context you said it in. You were trying
seriously listing out reasons you knew I better than she knew
you. And one of the reasons you listed was that you knew where
she lived. That was in a totally unironic context. Nobody believes
this. >> We have it on stream. >> Well, then you
can, Aiden, you can believe that I know where Eko lives. If you
want, I know where I live. >> No, I don't know if you actually
know where Eko lives, but you wanted her to >> She was
telling me that I was doxing her based off what I said. >> Yes.
Yes. But before that, what led to you joking about that if you
really were joking was her was you was you listing off uh reasons
you knew her and you listed off as one of those reasons totally
and totally unprompted that you knew where she lived. >> Wait,
no, no. I think you're mischaracterizing that. >> I I've
said it verbatim. I trust me. I said it verbatim. >> We
need to go back on the tape. >> Yeah, we'll go back on
the tape right now. I don't trust you. >> Okay. Tell me
why I said that. >> Oh, I'm aware that your screen Yeah.
I'll screenshot right now. >> Oh my god. Cuz I want to
actually reply to my own words. >> I'm aware I'm aware
that your grandma is dead. I'm aware where you live and where
your profession is. I'm aware of a whole bunch of [__]
>> You definitely don't sound like a
>> What the
>> Your grandma is dead. I'm aware where you live and where
your profession is. I'm aware of a whole bunch of [__]
>> You definitely don't sound like a stalker. You definitely
don't sound like a stalker with that one. >> I'm sorry.
She cried about her grandma being that dead. She cried about
it. >> Yeah. So, you're invoking things like her grandma
being dead, right? Cuz you're trying to get under her skin. And
then in the const trying to get under your skin, you bring up
that you know where she lives. Now, whether you actually knew
where she lived or not, wait, I'm about to I'm about to I'm about
to I'm about to I'm about to. But no, I'm not content. I'm saying
whether you actually knew where she lived or not is not the question.
The question here is you want her to believe that. Let's >> She
brought up She brought up her grandma because she was talking
about me releasing personally identifying information in myself.
>> You brought up her grandma. She did not bring up She
did not bring up her grandma here. >> No. No. She was bring
up me identifying PII and myself. And then I said that her grandmother
was dead. >> We were trying to help you identifying PII.
I got >> I didn't bring that up. >> You brought up
You brought up >> You brought up my that my grandmother's
dead. What does that have to do with >> People know that
because of a chub logic
>> from years ago. Why are you referring to years old?
All right, here's your Wait, so wait. I go if you're saying if
I tabulate things that are publicly identified uh previously
that's doxing. Nobody >> that was like a dunk on Aiden.
Maybe >> you're using things to threat you are using these
things as you know to compound your threat to make your threat
more threatening. >> So now while we're here, right while
we're here, uh I have the clip. I'm going to You're typing very
loud. I don't know if you're trying to res someone but I'm going
to play the clip right now. Full context. We're going to see
where you brought up the grandma. I'm going to let it play until
the end. Let's listen or >> Twitch. None of your business.
>> You realize that like when people are >> I'm trying
I'm trying to play the clip. Do I'm trying to play the clip.
I know it's hard for you. You just go like 1 minute without talking.
>> None of your business.
You don't have to do anything about it. >> Yeah, but I'm
pretty sure. >> So he's so sarcastic. >> You're the
one that me and Resi in the very beginning. We tried to have
an intervention for you to stop giving so much information about
yourself and you still have not figured it out. >> I go
I'm aware that your grandma is dead. I'm aware where you live
and what your profession is. I'm aware of a whole bunch of [__]
>> You definitely don't sound like a stalker. You definitely
don't sound like a stalker at that one. >> She cried about
her grandma being that dead and she cried about
what you >> Yeah. You know where she lives? What are you
talking about? >> Yeah. Wait,
I give my address to her address.
>> Why are you talking?
>> That was pretty psychotic. >> You play the whole
clip. You asked me to >> Didn't I give my address to resi?
>> Yeah, you did. You probably
are you still speaking? I'm playing the clip that you asked me
to play. Can you show up for two? >> I don't Why not just
mute your stream, bro? Why not just meet your Discord? What's
this guy doing? Meet your Discord. Stop sprinting at this person
who clearly has no self-control
and just
>> Aiden, you have a pause button, right? >> Wait,
see that's why you meet your Discord. I don't know. If he fights
with her for more than two seconds, it's
>> You Oh my, you're so not self-aware. You just criticized
me for pausing and talking over it. And now I'm playing the last
30. >> It's so over. >> You're in the sound of your
own voice. You narcissistic. Finish the clip. >> Playing
a clip.
I have something to add. >> Yeah. Add it after 30 seconds.
Wait. Resi. Wait. Wait. Resi's address.
>> No, I don't have Io's address at all. I only know where
she lives based off things that she said. >> No, that's
not true. I didn't give my address to Resi.
>> Okay. Wait. You literally just said it. >> Pause.
Aiden. Pause. >> Aiden. Pause. Pause. Pause. And pause.
And pause. And pause. And pause. And pause. What are you really
[__] >> You don't come. >> Who gave you
permission to speak? >> Aiden, did I not just say there
I don't have I don't have this information because of anything
that Resi has said to me. I said it because of stuff that she
has said publicly. >> What a powerful man. Who gave you
who gave you permission to speak? >> Not say that verbatim.
>> Yeah. And then you go and then you tease her by by saying
that you do have her or >> I'm joking with her. I'm joking
with >> Later you say shouldn't have shouldn't have given
it to resi. Let's watch that part. I go I'm joking with you that
you should not have the crazy
don't trust to the point that you do right now where you were
considering yourself not >> I did trust him but not anymore
you were addressed to him you dumb >> no you're right you're
completely right you're completely right um it's
>> I'm going to talk to you I'm going to talk to you I'm
going to do you
I would consider restraint
>> this progression of uh statements is not >> not
very good
okay I'll be asking resi for your >> please do it >> I
will be Yeah. >> And then you angrily leave the call. So
your emotions are climaxing. You know she's now concerned that
you over address and you actively play into it. >> Yes.
Cuz I like her feel bad.
Excuse me. So what I've been saying the whole time. Yes. Okay.
Glad we It took you that long to agree what I've been >> No.
No. No. God. When people do you realize that when people are
antagonizing you, if you antagonize them back, it feels good.
Even if overall you would prefer to not be in an antagonistic
situation. >> Sure. But I came here. You're saying I don't
even know what you said in the beginning this entire
respond to what you said. Most people Most people for being a
pedophile most people can >> I was making fun of Harry
Py.
>> Okay. You think Perry's a pedophile? >> Yes, I
do. >> For what reason? >> Because he made a very
strong defense of Starbase and the Cunny joke.
>> Uh, the Connie Inquisition is coming for you, Perry.
You're the next target of the Connie Inquisition.
Uh, somebody gifted Destiny a sub >> and claimed not to
know what Connie meant. Okay. >> Until afterwards. >> So,
he's defending like edgy like humor. I don't really know how
to >> Yeah, like edgy lollycon adjacent humor. And he calls
women he calls women that are over the age of 20 hags. Yeah.
Like you know it's what it is. >> Wait. Okay. So if I defend
like jokes is that does that make me I defend jokes >> kind
of. Yeah. It makes you apologize. >> Oh no.
There's some disastrous consequences for >> Okay. So okay.
So okay. So you're a doxer cuz you apparently made a dox joke.
Got it. We could do. >> Yeah. So you got Yeah. You're an
obsessed doctor. >> You realize that me being a doctor
of people that I think are morally repugnant is not the same
thing as people admitting to being a Right. >> So you are
totally one of psycho. Just be clear. No, I don't want to do
that. There's no reason to dox. But when I Wait, but you just
brought you just said dox morally repugnant in the context of
you bring up Iiko's dox. >> I don't think Io is morally
repug. >> So why say that?
>> You're making jokes about doxing. Are if you're making
jokes about doxing, isn't that better than defending jokes about
>> Because I think that it's worthwhile to dox people there.
>> Stronger. Isn't that a stronger thing to do than just
defending jokes about >> Yeah, but if if I code not fit
that categorization, why the would you say >> Because Okay,
wait. You just had we just had something we talked about. We
talked about docs. We talked about um who was it like me laughing
about it. So me making a joke about doxing is very different
than me actually doxing >> Yeah. Just like just like somebody
like making a joke is not them actually instead of making a joke
actually them >> bro you're actually awake for the stream
today. What's up? What is up? >> If the punch line of the
joke is that I'm a versus the punch line of the joke is that
it's so ridiculous that you're accusing me of being a Those are
two very different can be very funny. >> You just said
okay but didn't you like literally just say that you were like
trying to make like when I was like don't you think like when
you're when you're making jokes like that in the context where
she's genuinely concerned that you have her address. Don't you
think that's like a weird time or >> if somebody was accusing
you of a person that you've never if somebody was accusing you
accusing you of a person that you've never met that you never
had the capacity to meet or anything like that would you if you
were laughing and you were like haha yeah I them would that not
be a joke about the ridiculousness of the claim and not >> no
if somebody was like if somebody seriously believed I somebody
I would not I would not laugh and jokingly say yeah I read them
no I would not I wouldn't say that >> well so the joke
to the joke to me is the ridiculousness of the accusation that
I have in any way doxed like I go because here's the thing doesn't
release any information about anybody that talks to with me and
this is this is the thing I want to get out here is that he is
actually the most careful person when it comes to his associations
and that's probably why he's able to date somebody that's kind
of insane with me. I know he's the greatest person alive. You're
split. He'll be the devil in two months. How long you two been
together? >> Four months. >> Four months. Got it.
Okay. When you're dropping the All right. So, when you're dropping
the allegations about him on the TL, uh, please don't ask me
to care. >> So, you realize that like I have >> Aiden
Aiden is so
from early in the conversation, he's like trying to claw back
power now. That's all this is, right? He's like, if I can make
her cry, I will claw back all power in this conversation. That's
like
um a person that like severely abused me, right? And I don't
like I don't release a lot of information about them, like a
lot of identif
identifying information to them. I >> Why are you telling
me this like I care? >> I have their full name and their
address and everything like that. I haven't put that out there.
You think that I care about that? >> The great information,
I guess. I don't really care. I'm sorry. >> Yeah. Sorry
that happened to you. I >> I'm saying is that >> Aiden,
you're you're kind of like you're backing away from the point
that I'm making, which is that I'm clearly not a person who just
releases information because I have it. >> I'm not saying
I'm not saying releasing information. Wait, wait, wait. What
I just said was you'll be making allegations against him in a
few months, right? And you're making allegations. >> Why
do you think that? Why do you think that, Eden? >> I just
feel like this. You know what? You're right about one thing.
This is Yes. This part is totally vibes. Yes. >> Vibes.
Not the com with you. And I not the combo. No, this is this is
the first time I've real
>> I'd say
>> I guess maybe this based on her reaction to Perry. I
mean, she's calling Perry at this point. >> I don't know,
man. Face to face. >> I am talking to you. I have spoken
to you. You actually You think everyongers and it's okay. And
it's duck. understand. I understand the hustle, but when it comes
to my personal relationships and my personal associations, yeah,
I'm going to take it a little bit more personally. Like, >> nothing
nothing before tonight was just vibes. Uh, after this conversation,
any opinion I had about your relationship being bad has been
like strengthened like times 100 and like the potential for you
to like make allegations against him in the given future. I would
bet on it. Uh, and yeah, that part is vibes, but that's like
the first vibes based argument I made. So, you can't really use
like a post rationalization of your weight around I'm a weight
around like Resi's neck when the weight has been his problem
with Ieko, right? And what I've been doing this entire time is
I've been saying, "Listen, like I have concerns about what she's
been doing, but ultimately you do you. Like I I don't care. Like
I want you to mend things." Even early on when he wasn't communicating
with Iiko, I was the one that was saying, "Hey, you probably
deserve that. She probably deserves an explanation for why she
upset you so much, right?" And yeah, I understand that I'm revealing
a little bit of [__] about Resi right there. But
it's also to defend my own [__] character. Well,
I' I've been slandered because listen, Aiden, I've been slandered
as a worm pum as somebody who has been actively trying to get
in the middle of his relationships when no, what I've been doing
is, if anything, advocating for [__] clemency for
for sanity in the space. You're the voice of reason. Got >> Believe
it or not, yeah, in this situation, yeah, Aiden, and I understand
that I'm very emotional and I'm talking really fast and I might
talk over people, right? But I would hope that if you get to
know me on oneonone level, I'm very reasonable. >> That's
never going to happen. I don't need to I don't give particularly
care that you're emotional. I care that like you've demonstrated
inherent lack of self-control. And I think that's like a very
like dangerous trait for somebody to have. I also think you're
like outwardly manipulative. You tactically invoke your abuse
to garner sympathy. You tactically cry to garner sympathy for
me. And it worked for IO. It's not going to work for me cuz I've
dealt with people like you before. >> Aiden, that's entirely
your >> No, I got a cookie. I got a cookie. Yeah. ction
of my like my actions that that I can't do anything about. You
have a reason for you to color my actions that way and I'm honestly
not interested in fighting back against it. I know who I am.
I know why I cry. I know why I don't cry. I know that's optically
very >> I know you do and I know that's why it's and I
know that's why this is getting to you because I know you know
it's true even if you're not going to say it >> White chocolate
macadamia. >> No, it's not getting to me. It's you trying
to obuscate and you trying to say in some way that I'm being
disingenuous when I've shown my genuine intention to go. I've
used this opportunity to say to Io, I like you. I don't have
any reason to dislike you. So that's obviously not true. upset.
Aiden totally tactical every other >> I do think um as
much as I'm clowning Aiden I do think this is not far off like
she knew that she'd said something crazy with the doxing thing
and then it was like oh started crying started like I feel like
we went through like a whole playbook right there right analysis
>> what do I have to benefit what do I have to gain from
this >> the thing that I the thing the thing that I potentially
gained from this is that I go and resi maybe in the future they
could become friends or be personable in some way and that's
>> resi no it's not it's not happening um I I have cut
people off But when once once something like this happens, it's,
you know, I wish them well and that's it. And that's great. We
move on. That's it. >> I think that's good. And I think
that's good. And honestly, the reason the only reason I'm upset
about this right now is because Sunday went on res and told him
to stop talking about it and then you had a whole stream afterwards
where you kept talking about it. That's the only thing. Shut
up, Aiden. The only reason I'm thinking about this right now
is because the only reason I'm thinking about this right now
is because of that stream. Otherwise, I had put this off to the
side. I said I go is she has her own community. She's doing her
own thing. She's doing her own. It does not me. It does not impact
Resi. is refusing to give me her her information so I can file
a restraining order to protect >> I honestly >> I'm
just throwing that out there. >> Honestly, please go. >> I
go I go. If you want to unblock me, I'll send you my full name
and address so you can >> She doesn't want to talk. She
doesn't want to talk to you directly. >> So, I'm not talking
to you. >> Okay. Well, if you really want to file a restraining
order against me, I will give you the information, but you're
>> Can you tell to just give me that?
>> Right now would be awesome. >> Yeah, he's he's
actually trying to call me. If you just let him know if he wants
to call him, uh I think he can join my server. I'll send him
invite was not just to be honest. It seems like to duck her leave.
>> Yeah, I guess she's telling I don't I don't I don't
know what's going on. Honestly, Aiden, I'm literally going to
uh go do whatever. >> Just be like J should be like J should
be like munch m much cookie yum. >> You have to do >> because
she actually freaks me the [__] out. Like she's not
sane. Like I don't know where she invented all I I haven't even
seen what she said before I
>> Got it. Uh yeah, she you could just watch that. She
It was like insane because we weren't debating on anything part
like we're talking about like doxing in general, how to define
it. She called in like pushed me on it and she got like so viscerally
emotional about I was just like in shock. I don't know if I was
being trolled. Um but yeah, my just to be clear, my opinions
on her have like nothing to do with you. I formed these opinions
on my own through talking to her, through interacting with her.
Um I just I mean I think you give her a lot more credit than
I would have. Uh to me, she comes off as very manipulative. Uh
she knows exactly what she's doing. Um and I'm not going to fall
for the tears like at all. >> No. Yeah. I I also I agree.
I am someone who because I am susceptible to stuff like that,
I have a hard cut off with anything that even looks like a flavor
of that to to quote, you know. Um >> yeah. Get it documented.
Get it documented that you've used a stream that you explicitly
ask her to stop communicating with you. Uh and then if she continues
to do so, makes alts and stuff. You may have a case for a stream
or I don't know. I mean, she does seem like she's like actually
obsessed. >> I'm going to Yeah, I'm going to do whatever.
Like I have I have no idea where all of this stuff came from.
Like our my DMs with res. We didn't like hang out in private
VCs. Like most of what you see of our friendship, you know, aside
from just like little chatting about whatever in DMs casually,
we don't have like this like very elaborate friendship. So I
>> I would just ask Resi like what he thinks to be honest.
If Resi's not willing to publicly say he thinks Io had like a
crush on him with like some kind of evidence. I I feel like it's
just
>> It's all very um uh disturbing. >> Got it. Well,
with that um I'm give a call real quick. He doesn't want to call
while you're in here. I don't think you >> Oh no. What?
Why? >> He just told me he's not willing to call him while
you're here. >> I have no She's going to break res off
and wear like wear it as an amulet. Not ideal. Oh, look. It's
the uh it's the thing I've done forever and now Destiny's trying
to frame this as a Kiwi Farms thing. The not ideal. Not the best.
Very concerning. Very concerning
>> Exclamation marks, guys. Apparently >> crash on
you. I have my own theory.
>> Oh, like you're not allowed to. >> I that would
be my assumption. >> All right. Well, uh >> you sweep
for resi's callin. You're sweeping, by the way. No way. That's
crazy.
If I sweep, then I'm sweeping. >> You know, I'm gonna I'm
going to ask to get in if he starts saying any wacky. All right,
I'll try. I'll try. >> All right. All right. Thanks. See
you. >> All right. I'll call Resi oneonone now. >> Hey,
man. What's literally just woke up? >> You did just wake
up. >> Yeah. I want to like So, we're just I'm just having
duck consented to Sunday and Sunday can give it to Tao. I'm not
interacting with I don't want to interact with Tao. >> That's
That's fair enough. Um >> I mean, >> I saw like a
bit of it like I I like So, what was the first part? Was it about
the one Perry guy and spicy chat posting like Lily Max face or
something? >> Yeah. Um, shout out to Perry
who um, shout out to Perry actually who just put me on a social
stream. Although I think somebody actually put me on a social
stream first. I can't remember who it was. Somebody showed me
social stream like weeks ago, months ago maybe, and I didn't
do it. And then Perry, I asked Perry because Perry does the thing
as well, right? Does slogy fit into any of your recent crosswords?
You sick freak. I stopped doing those. Uh, women stopped coming
on the stream. We stopped doing all the daily quests.
It was just it was just everybody likes doing them, you know.
You told me to ask Perry. Oh, no, no, no. Somebody gave me social
stream like a long time ago. >> Like, oh, Mal showed me
social stream.
I'm pretty sure >> we're talking about it was like a neutral
come and debate and she like makes it about them talking about
her. So, it's clear she has some like personal involvement to
this. And I explained to her Yeah. But I explained to her why
her case wouldn't like based on the way she described it to me
why that would not meet my definition of doxing. Um, >> well,
yeah. I mean, it's it's literally just face doxing though. We
have a full term for it, right? Well, yeah, but >> and
it's also like the same term that a lot of people in this community
have used for JTO and everybody else, right? Face doxing. Guess
he hasn't doxed Jtock, but allegedly has faced dox him, >> Well,
he did. He posted a link to an account that he believed contained
Jtock's full name. Whether that was actually his full name or
not, not >> Yeah, I've seen that part, but like but when
it first started with JTO, he only like faced doxed him and that's
when we started the doxing conversation, right? >> Well,
I'm actually glad I have you here cuz maybe I might need to maybe
I might be able to have a more reasonable discussion on this.
There was no >> I don't I mean, okay, >> it's quick.
It's quick. It's quick. I just want to ask, did so I get straight
answers. Um, did they find her face by by linking a channel that
she said was hers in a Discord server to her and then there was
an unlisted video on there that they clicked on? >> And
you didn't disinvigate your pronouns. Who are we saying as her?
Who? >> Sorry, Duckbringer.
>> Did they find her face uh through an old channel? Perry,
>> whoever whoever was a part of her face. >> Yeah,
originally. Yeah, that was like there was like some old channel
that she was doing like urban exploration stuff with. Yeah, that
was very >> um I think Queenan used a different chat overlay
to do this only with YouTube chat. I don't think he's social
stream, but it is it looks the same. It might be a stream elements
one. There's like a there's one of these things that does this
for YouTube chat. I don't think it was the same. >> Her
face first. Yeah. >> Okay. But that but that's because
she she brought up the channel was hers,
>> Um not as far as I can tell. I think it had like some
like Duckbringer tag on it or something. I I'm not I'm going
to be honest. I don't really remember at this >> Well,
what she said to me was that she discussed it in Discord. Um
that doesn't necessarily get people. >> Yeah, I think that
that happened before me and her really started talking much like
we probably talked a little bit about the one draw the drama
she was involved in earlier this year, but nothing super personal
I think by that. Dark streams with her face cam on.
Face on cam. How often does she stream with her face on cam would
be the question. >> Yeah. Based on >> Yeah, based
on what she described it to me, it didn't meet my burden of doxing
because she established the link to the >> Yeah. No, I
don't. Yeah, I don't think so either. I also just I'm just going
to be honest. I don't really think that the thing Spencer did
meets the level of doxing either. So, >> I think it does.
>> The reason the chat's like this is cuz my person know
how the Spencer stuff came about. So, if you want to illuminate
me on that, that would be cool, too. I actually No, I haven't
looked into it. >> Sure. So my my personal definition of
doxing is when somebody else uh takes personally identifying
information uh and links it establishes a link between that and
somebody's uh anonymous online persona um or online persona put
another information attached to it. Now now Willie Mack was getting
married. He didn't reveal this under his online persona. He didn't
tweet about it put on YouTube etc etc. Somebody >> he did
kind of acknowledge that it was a >> Yes. Yeah. There's
no fixing because there's a picture of him in it with a running
announcement. So you can't really dispute it. Um what happened
was that the picture Spencer posted I don't know. I actually
>> So Spencer So Spencer Okay. I'll tell you exactly what
happened. Right. I believe it's on Kiwi Farms. Somebody on Kiwi
Farms is like Facebook app. I think he's a dumb ass for this.
Uh the pictures of the wedding were up online. I think somebody
used like Facebook search app or something and found uh the wedding
photos. They were getting married. Um somebody puts this on Kiwi
Farms and then Bonata utilized it and tweets out like picture
of them together and the wedding announcement or what and and
Spencer screenshots tweet um and puts it into spicy chat and
he takes the photo uncensored with his wife or future wife out
of the bad tweet and posts that as well and he says I'll delete
this. Don't worry or something acknowledging he knows it's wrong.
>> I saw the I saw the thing. It's like Perry then Spencer
I'll delete this in a second. Don't worry. And then we'll talking.
I recall I remember seeing that >> Yeah. So because because
Willie did not link this because Willie did not link this private
information or not private because Willie didn't link his personal
information uh to his online persona the people that contributed
to the establishment of that link would be doxing him. >> Think
that's fair. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think amount of dox
them. Um I guess like I mean it's it's redoxing them. >> I'd
say the another part of the doxing is like explicitly the wedding
date, right? You're literally posting like a date and time they'll
be somewhere specific with like a location. That's >> It
was already public because Batman link, right? >> Well,
while we're on the subject, I didn't want to ask can we stick
on this for just a second? So like did it and then Spencer propagated
it, right? >> Okay. So all right. I know like I know like
I'm literally just woke up. I'm kind of just I didn't even pay
attention to this part of it. So that >> like some people
are saying it wasn't that bad what happened to Willie. I don't
know how bad the goat fumodor tweet was with the p piece of like
the bad empanada thing but like the fact that his wedding day
got doxed that that was like crazy to me. Like that's that's
way worse than just having like your face posted or something
>> that makes like Destiny >> that's like thousands
of dollars to reschedu potentially or are you just like well
I guess I'll take the chance >> posting it and stuff doxing
as well. Is that right? Like we're just that's that falls into
your thing >> technically that would be my definition but
I typically >> that make like well does that does that
make the deal that retweeted Destiny also doxing him? >> Probably
I probably wouldn't say that. The reason I would say that okay
so the reason I wouldn't say that is because they've seen the
links already you know what that's fair enough.
I didn't say it but like us even talking about it the other day.
>> Sorry about tweet. So So I typically a typical established
qualifier for doxing and I have I have forgot to or got to mine
occasionally. I don't think it's like super important when we're
saying a doxing is intent right
because you didn't include that in your initial like every single
person that ever drives doxing always says something >> almost
almost always malicious. >> It always says this malicious
thing and I just I think at the end of I me personally um I think
that it's kind of useless because then somebody's like well I
just was trying to be nice and defendant like I don't really
like buying back. It just seems like bad internet etiquette if
anything you know. I think that at some point I don't know I
don't really believe people online so yeah like I don't know
whatever yeah sure so faceing um would I say that them finding
ducks old channel would be
>> uh I don't know I guess I have to see what the private
conversations were that duck alluded to >> they weren't
private documents they're on a server I don't access um >> or
whatever conversations they were say like you show your face
to me right now she also used that channel to publicly chat in
people's comments so good point but while we're here while we're
here on the subject um did you give Duckbrer I's >> no
I don't have IO's address I never got IO's address we were going
to meet up like this month ago originally but no we don't I was
I never got our address so I have literally no idea at all >> that's
reassuring cuz on stream earlier darker was uh was telling me
where she lived and then I was like did resi give her my address?
>> Dude, I can't believe we're in 2x there >> and
she was like playing into it. >> That's probably it. It's
just if I'm going to be honest like it's Yeah. I No, I I don't
believe that she has any of information like and she does didn't
get it from me. >> Have you seen the clip? >> I know
who would have it. So, have I seen the clip? >> I was starting
to watch the stream. >> You want to see the clip real quick?
>> Um I'll probably just watch the stream. Like if you
want to show the clip, go ahead. Yeah, why not? >> All
right, cool. Yeah, I >> think it's like right around Wait,
sorry, wrong part. I think it's like right around here. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. >> Can I ask you um so before I [__]
>> called in, what generally would you say the tenor of
the conversation was regarding Ieko? >> So, so what happened
was Duckbringer got really angry in our doxing conversation and
left and then Duckbrer called back in and Duckbringer accused
me of sweeping for Ieko. Um I first and trying to like walk me
through, oh, do you know this about this IO drama? This was and
it's like I don't really know IO all that well. I don't know
every facet of her drama. I moderated a debate because I can
moderate a debate on something I don't have that much prior knowledge
about. both parties are substantiating their position at that
given point in time. Um but uh and both parties agreed that I
was fair to both of them. So Ducker came in and started talking
about IGO and how I swept for her. But real quick, let's go.
Let's play a clip. >> Sorry. Yeah. I just was trying to
figure out exactly what was going on with that cuz I didn't really
I couldn't really figure out the one to one about how that happened.
So
>> my stalker somebody
I will tell people
for this. >> All right. [__] I had the wrong
time. Great streamer here. Bear with me. >> It's going
to be screeching. I got it. >> Yeah. I just want to make
sure cuz whoever cut this clip apparently is like um and they
like didn't cut it when it began. It's like right around here.
All right, cool. >> Go ahead. You're fine. >> Sorry
about the situation. This is >> Okay, I am tapping. Okay,
I'm tapping. I'm sorry. Res's here. I'm tapping out. I got to
tap out. I got to tap out. Sorry. I'm like falling asleep. Okay,
I love you guys. This is a good stream. This is like uh 10 hours
of stream today or something. Like 10 hours of stream. All right,
I can pick this up at some point. Hold on. >> In my in
my timeline of friendship, this is barely a blip. Okay, your
idea of toxic toxic relationship, friendship, whatever that is
a very narrow world. It is a narrow, miserable world where you
are just controlling each other and and just dealing with each
other's emotions and having a bunch of feelings, but it doesn't
actually go anywhere.
>> Wait, wait, hold on. Yes. >> Am I wrong like when
I'm listening to this that Io is continuing to just talk about
me? Am I wrong about that or no? >> Well, because you're
like an integral part of the conversation. I guess that's
>> She She called in. >> Why did I want to call in?
Cuz Duckbringer was there. Oh, Duckbringer was talking and I
That's No, no, no, no, no. Res's totally wrong. I Duckbringer
was talking about Iiko. Absolutely talking about Ieko and that
dragged Iiko into the conversation. She was talking about Iiko
because of comments that she said she was revealing private like
what that Aiko had like a crush on Resir. Like that can't be
that can't be Aiko's fault. That has to be Duckbringer's fault.
That's not just Ieko talking about Resi for no reason. >> She
called in because Duckbringer was talking about her like Io is
a grown woman. Why does anybody >> a total nightmare to
deal with? And if resi is going to like defend, I'm sorry. >> I
don't care that your grandma is dead. I'm aware where you live
and where your profession is. I'm aware of >> that. The
grandma dead stuff was because on Shed Logics, she would always
tell dudes that she their moms and this one dude's like, "Well,
my mom's dead." And then like a week or so later, DK taunts her
because her grandma died and she cried to get out of a debate.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I've heard that meme. I don't really like
I don't really care. I don't care about like people go low for
jokes. I care when it's like they're clearly doing it out of
anger. Not to be funny. You definitely don't sound like a stalker.
You definitely don't sound like a stalker with that one. >> I'm
sorry. She cried about her grand dead. She cried about it. [__]
>> a stalker with that. You definitely don't sound like
a stalker. >> Live and where your profession is. I'm aware
of a whole bunch of [__] about >> You definitely
don't sound like a stalker. You definitely don't sound like a
stalker. She says, "I'm aware of where you live. I know what
your profession is." Wrote that one. >> Yeah. I have no
idea at all. I I legitimately have zero idea. I mean, her she's
a streamer. >> Yeah. Yeah, she talked about how she does
uh she just generally
Iiko generally like gestures to like what she does aside from
streaming, but that's about it. That's all I know. I have no
idea what Aiko does even with that. >> Yeah. Well, just
at the end of this real >> her grandma being about you.
It's about you. So, >> she cried about it.
>> What about what you >> Yeah, you know where she
lives? What are you talking about?
>> Wait, I gave my address to
>> Shouldn't I give my address to Resi? >> Yeah,
you did. You probably shouldn't have, [__] So, so
>> it would be so funny if Aiko just didn't give him the
address and that whole thing was like made up and
Jesus
not true. Like I just making [__] up. >> So,
okay. But so she asked that, right? But then Duckbringer goes
and confirms that. So even if >> I feel less bad about
Duckbringer leaning into that now, but it's still it was still
like psychotic. But at least that's not possible if if what Resi
is saying is >> even if I go like got it totally wrong.
duck ringers now and just like confirm
>> Yeah, I have no I have literally no idea. I'm going
to be honest. I have completely unawares of this. I have no idea
why. >> Let's be real. If if Perry did that to some woman
was like, "Yeah, uh and and that guy gave me your ducks and now
I'm coming for you." Like I feel like people go, "Oh, awesome
cinema."
>> She's trying to scare >> this taunting Io for
OCD or something. So I >> You're totally unwilling to talk
to about this, by the way? >> Yeah, totally unwilling.
I feel I feel like I feel like that I feel like that is what
how people would take it. I feel like that's how people would
talk about >> God, there's not really I guess I can't do
anything about that bridge. Um but yeah, she she was like using
uh she was using like the prospect of knowing like Aika's address.
>> These are not the same things. How are they not the
same things? >> Her skin um and using you to like invoke
that narrative. She later goes on and clarifies when she's calmed
down a little bit. Um but I feel like you should know that >> I
was mistaken. Yeah, I'd say like I don't think um like I look
at the Duckbringer thing like at least a little bit less insane
now, >> right? She >> Yeah, I mean I understand >> she
led a chat into believing that you gave Io's address to her.
>> Okay. Yeah. I mean Okay. Yeah, I see that at this point.
I'm I'm understanding that. You know, probably have a conversation
with the person. So >> I I guess my >> Yeah, I don't
know. Like I'm not gonna I'm not I I have to >> Perry is
obviously joking when he does that stuff.
Ha. I feel like Perry's joking. H He is joking. H I don't know.
There's always something about the Merc I'm going to cut your
head off and three-pointers with it that felt like there was
something real happening there. I don't know how to explain it.
>> Look, I want to look at everything cuz Yeah. Just I
probably should do that, >> Yes. Yes. I guess my qu You
know, I'm not trying to set you up. Okay. We've been You've been
raiding me since my early days. >> Like I I get that. I
I just, you know, like it's >> if if you're not going to
talk to >> say whatever you want, man. Like I I I don't
really have like as much trust in most people. Like I I'll send
you [__]
a fair to not really trust >> Well, that's fine. I don't
need you to like open up open your heart out to me. But like
even from perspective of caring about Duckbrer, like do you not
feel like this is like a crazy way to engage online? Uh how she's
been talking to me? >> How she's been talking. I guess
you'd have to rewatch the stream. >> Crazy way for her
to engage online. I >> Why she Why is Aiden so
dude Aiden's just like This is the same as what was it? Do you
disavow Tommy C right now? Will you disavow Tommy C right now?
Wasn't he doing that in a Twitter space and now it's like, will
you disavow your girlfriend for being rude to me on a stream?
Would you res will you disavow your girlfriend right now? Please
>> feel like you have >> like do you not feel like
>> most people like I'll
not really trust anybody. >> Well, that's fine. I don't
need you to like open up open your heart out to me. But like
even from perspective of caring about Duckbrer, like do not feel
like this is like a crazy way to engage online. Uh how she's
been talking to me. how she's been talking to him. >> I
guess you don't. >> How she's been talking to me. How she's
been talking to me.
>> Crazy way for her to engage online. >> Um I feel
like it has like the same tenor as the previous conversation.
It's just that
that was funny. That's like the best part of her engaging online.
>> This time it's directed towards Eko. Like the one she's
the secondary part of the conversation that comes in after about
30 minutes. >> Duck. She's always been like kind of like
freaky sparky like this. And she did this in previous that one
previous conversation with you too. But like the other thing
the other thing that like concerns me is like she'll go from
lashing out to like supposedly crying. Uh it just like it feels
like very like manipulative. I don't know maybe you know her
better than I do. Um I just like I don't like I don't have like
>> Did she Did she cry during this >> Yes. Yes. >> And
it felt to me very tactical, very manipulative. And when when
I called her on it and it came back to like >> that wasn't
that isn't wrong. It was >> argument details. She went
right back into her original mode. Um I don't know. This isn't
Iiko's like explicitly clarified that she wants Doc to stop.
That was like disturbing how Yeah, that's a that's a pretty solid
analysis,
>> Contact's an announce stream after it >> from
what I saw. Link to me on
she followed and that she posted a puddle. >> Throw my
stream chat in my Discord so I can grab it here. Yeah. >> Chat
in one of those chats, right? >> Yes. But I also don't
think you could like complain about somebody stalking you and
you're like going out and actively contacting them. >> I
mean like I very specifically said that I shouldn't care about
the chatters during the conversation that we had like the last
time we had them. So like a little less sympathetic, right? >> Yeah.
Yes. My problem with it's not like whether you're sympathetic.
People do this all the time, right? When something crushes their
standard, they're like, "Well, personally, I don't care." >> Like,
you know, people do it all the time, but like we don't disown
our chatters for going in other places to do things, right? >> Yes.
But this is Okay. But she's engaged and like I mean this stream
albeit it was a new revelation like using her address to go at
her. I mean at one point when we I didn't even come to the conversation
at one point she accidentally calls me Iiko before anyone has
said her name and we're talking about doxing and then she calls
back in to go on a rant about how I swept for Iiko. Do you feel
like it's like a little bit like obsessed?
>> I mean, yeah. I mean, probably. I would say sure, but
again, like I'm not >> I'm not going to like I'm not going
to middle on I'm not going to >> like Okay, so if I want
to say it's obsession. Um, again, like that kind of I hate to
say it seems like the kind of dur of the area to be like obsessed
with your enemies, right? >> To be like emotionally obsessed.
She's like on tears on stream. I don't think anyone in our general
sphere, at least anyone I talk to or know of does that. I mean,
okay. >> There's people we ag Well, to be clear, there's
people we a log and laugh at, but do you not feel like she's
doing a little more than just like a logging and laughing at?
Do you feel like she's like very emotionally involved in this?
I think it's like kind of evident.
>> Yeah. I just don't know what that I I hate like I'm
not trying to be stupid or something, but I just don't fully
I I don't really know what the I don't know what rule I could
make about that. You know what I mean? I don't know how I would
like mechanize that as something that I would say wouldn't condemn
the rest of the kind of a logging that we do. You know what I
mean? Like I would assume that like there's going to be like
let's say you know I mean we both we both believe Cameron like
did some weird with that right? >> What the Iiko's grandmother
died a week before Destiny had chicken waffles with Nick Fentes
and since her grandma survived the Holocaust was emotional about
the way Destiny was cool with Nick talking about the in the way
he does and asking if fans who wanted to chat were that guy didn't
want to chat. That guy literally just did a driveby. He did a
driveby, threw up like a a hang 10 hand sign at the camera, and
Nick was like, "Are you one of the one of the funniest moments
I've ever seen on a stream before this guy just walked by and
he's like, "You guys are so serious." He like throws up a hand
symbol at the camera, and Nick's like, "Are you one of the weirdest
dude, it was such a weird
anyway,
so she joined in a a call into Chud's talk to talk with Destiny
and cried about Destiny allowing his viewers to think Nick was
cool and personable. Oh boy, that's rough. >> Like would
it be unreasonable for >> I don't believe I don't I'm I'm
I'm 50/50. I'm 50/50. >> Okay, but like let's Do you think
that it's reasonable that somebody could think that about Cameron?
>> Okay. So, you can't see a way somebody would think that
Cameron ared that girl? >> I can't see it. No, I can see
a way they think that. >> Okay. So, so at that point we're
dealing with somebody having an opinion of someone which you
don't necessarily agree with and then they might get emotional
because they're like, "Oh,
>> resi come on. You're just like this is like a totally
fictional scenario that we wouldn't and it's not just like I
know they're coming with a hypothetical, right? But I can't see
any drama where somebody was like crying over the person that
they were a-logging. Like I don't think that that happens. >> I
guess I I just I just like I feel okay. So like I don't really
know >> there should be like a level of control, right?
If you're if you're gonna like review somebody's content consistently,
there should be some level of control,
>> Much about like Lulcow a farming. Like I know Pixie
Terry and that like the one dude with Pixie Terry, that's like
my favorite LCO absolutely got to that >> Well, I don't
know who any of those people are >> at that point. Again,
I will say the emotional connection was too high, but
>> it kind of happens. Again, >> that's that guys
if that's true. >> If we're going to talk about like people
crying on stream, I just don't >> I hate to say it. Maybe
it's me being from Twitch pull. I don't think that's like a super
abnormal thing. I hate to say it. >> Okay. I think it's
>> again this is me coming from Twitch pole. There are
a lot of people that cried in Twitch pole to get out of stuff
which started the crying meme. >> Yes. But but resi I've
seen debate panels on Twitch poll and it would be like let's
say me and you are like debating I don't know uh how we think
the economy should be run
but like but like imprompted imprompt screaming about the economy
like scream out of nowhere comes the conversation doesn't have
time to escalate. You're screaming and then you leave and then
you call back in and you start ranting about me sweeping for
someone that I barely know >> and then >> like so
like an Anavar talk, right? >> I don't know. You can't
really use I don't know who I said is the person was like one
private. Yeah, >> throw some money. >> Throw some
money in the pot. Doesn't make it better. Like I'm not going
to say like completely emotionally regulated on this. I've like
from what I've seen. No, but it's just Yeah. Like if you want
that's >> Isn't I don't know the I don't know the Lord
with her too much. Wasn't wasn't uh wasn't like uh Anna considered
to have an unhealthy relationship with the >> Sorry. Um
Chlo, thank you. Here's a time stamp. I grabbed the announcement
video, but uh this is time stamped or whatever.
8 minutes he comes in at comes in here. Good. We'll check it
out right after >> To manipulate her and like post and
stuff. Um yeah, she had she had an unhealthy relationship with
the internet because the object of her desired destiny in private
was telling her separate things than what he was saying in public
about her and was saying she was stalking him in private and
she wanted to correct the record over and over again >> because
she's very because she's very susceptible to how the public is
viewing her, right? >> Yeah. So yeah, and that's all well
and good. I understand. That's why I'm saying this is probably
an Anavore type situation with Duck because it seems more like
that. >> Do you think
a public for like a public whatever? Yeah.
Destiny but Destiny's like a huge streamer with like thousands
of luck concurrent like he's calling her she's only known because
of him right and he's calling as far as I know unless something
I'm missing and he's publicly referring to her as a stalker that's
going to have like way more of a detriment somebody's going to
like care about that like to miles more than they like this doesn't
really the level of discourse but does not necessitate the or
or just the reaction I've seen >> yeah sure well I mean
you guess
>> I don't even know if like I I just need to see evidence
of a bunch of these things right so I she came in Duckbrer came
in and was like oh I was doing like all these things talking
about me right and I've seen No evidence yet versus tiebound
going on. Last hope >> here like duck gets like what like
10 to 20 viewers at you know on like a stream and I gets five
times that. Anavar when she was skiing was getting like what
1 to 300 and Destiny was doing like 2 to 3k. So it's like five
times versus 10 times like space uh size differential. >> I
mean proportionately >> yeah but were those 300 consistent
viewers watching for her or were those like hate watchers from
Destiny's >> I think she had like if I had to make a guess
at like Anavore Peak uh without Destiny stuff she was doing like
95 to like 120. >> So yeah. So yeah. No way.
Anavar was not getting a lot of Anavar did not have organic engagement
at all. Okay, that was not even remotely organic engagement.
Come on. >> Like watching on like behalf of Destiny or
cuz they follow Destiny. >> I think Destiny I mean Destiny
at that time was pushing like equivalent to Zarker numbers if
I recall. I think it was like 2 to 4,000. >> Yeah, 4,000
concurrent. Yeah, 4,000 >> And I think like 4,000 was probably
his drama thing cuz even like when it was >> that's just
on one platform, right? You have a the website. >> Yeah,
this is this is No, this is Yeah, this is what the website too.
Yeah. Okay. But like we can't gather information from the website
because I don't have that. >> My server at that point had
like 50,000 me. I mean like relative to her he was >> I
got dude I got like 600 members in my discord like >> he's
still a Twitch at that point as >> You don't you don't
think like talking about this like Destiny like going on and
calling I don't know me a stalker or whatever like like that's
like going to be a huge him back then even would be a huge audience
that I'm fighting with or dealing with and to like somebody >> Wow.
Wow. Imagine Destiny going online and just lying about you with
like a audience like 10 to 15 times bigger than yours. Wow.
Wow, man. I can't imagine what that would be like. Somebody like
may not may be more sensitive to public perception, etc., etc.
That's obviously like a way bigger deal. But yeah, I mean, I
just don't think it's proportionate in that. Um, I don't think
that like I go who quite, you know, I'm sorry, I go, but like
it's kind of like a nobody. Um, like talking on her streams like
a huge deal that's going to necessitate this level of crashing
out like coming to my stream to confront me about sweeping for
Igo, which I still don't know how I did. >> Okay. So, sorry.
I'm sorry. What was the question exactly? Can you say that one
more time? I apologize. I just kind of got lost there. You need
a statement. Yeah, I was just Yeah, I was just saying like a
maybe unjustified emotional reaction in the case of Anna um is
probably going to be like way more justified or or understandable
uh relative to Igo talking about duck bringing on her like streams
and nobody >> Yeah, I guess like the issue there is that
I don't think Duck sees Io as a streamer I guess is probably
is again I'm guessing man I can't speak for Duck. I don't really
know what's going on in her head half the time. I woke up to
this. I have no idea what's going on. So like yeah I I don't
think I can like really answer to like what Duck views IO as
properly. >> Do you I mean >> I hate to say it like
that cuz it sounds like it does sound hopy. I get it. you know,
that's why I'm not really engaging with any of it. Yes. >> I
don't I'm not gonna tell you what to do. I don't know if you're
anyway, but I mean, I wouldn't I wouldn't like be like I don't
know. I wouldn't enable this. I'd probably give an ultimate of
some kind, but it's up to you. Um >> yeah, it's probably
gonna happen one way or the other, like, you know, but yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, I can start sooner or later for everyone
jump ship, but yeah. Um >> I mean, yeah, it's it's just
again like Okay. Yeah, I know. That's that's already I think
we're already there from last week's conversation, man. So, >> yeah,
I hate to say it like that, but like realistically like Yeah,
it's you know, it's okay. I'm fine with it. It's I'll I'll tell
her, "Yeah, you probably need to get offline from literally all
these faces because yeah, there's not really anything here for
Duck." Oh, aren't you? Um, I I'm like, >> what? What? What?
What? Why didn't he just ask that? >> That's super confusing.
I've said this before. I don't really know how to turn myself
or whatever. I've never been able to do that. I don't even really
I also say this. The more that I look into like gender stuff,
the less I understand that as well, so not really capable of
answering that. So, not satisfactory. >> Yeah, at this
point I probably recommend men. Um, but yeah, I mean I everyone's
going to be mad and I'm asking exactly what they want. Obviously,
I'm not a Okay, people just typing in caps. Aiden. >> Exactly
what they want. Go ahead. Well, >> I don't know. >> Aiden
had his ability to choose women taken away from him as a child.
Okay. And we don't mock him for that. Hello. Why did somebody
just join my stream so late? What's up, moral? How's it going?
>> I'm okay. How are you? Smile.
>> Uh, good. I'm watching the end of this resi duck whatever
this mess. Like hour 11 of streaming right now.
Today kind of money. Okay. Money. >> Actually, it's probably
more like hour >> No, they want they're saying my name.
They're not typing anything. Well, I know that it's because they
just want you to like go harder and stuff and probably or you
go harder on me, I >> Dude, can I do me like one favor?
Okay, I know you're I know you're strong enough to like sit in
a call. >> I'm not taking a call. >> Come on. It's
like this like telephone. You can leave if she gets out of hand.
I >> yeah, you don't have I don't have to respond to IO.
>> No, no, you don't have to. It was everyone's life 10
times easier. >> Everyone's life. No, it's for it's for
you to make money and like and I want you to make money, but
like I don't I'm not doing this. >> You You will not talk
to IEO. >> Will not talk to Io. Correct. >> Can you
at least ask why? Would that be >> I've already No, because
I've already explained it last week. Like I like I don't know
what else to say. >> I forgot. I forgot. You just repeat
it at least. No, I think I'm good on that, >> Really? Can't
repeat. Understand? >> All right. That's kind of the move.
Sad stuff. Sad stuff. Well, yeah. I don't know. What I would
do if you watch the stream and then I would go watch Misery of
Stephen King and kiss if that's like what you want for the rest
of your life. Um, yeah. >> I'm probably just going to go
I'll probably watch a bit of the streams and I'm just going to
go live and just do my stream. So, >> hop on. Hop on. >> Take
care. >> Yeah, you're getting mad at me. I didn't push
hard enough. I've been going now for nearly six hours. Uh, I
don't really talk about the lore. Uh, I don't think I made you
made you look insane to anyone. Anyone who's watching, I don't
think anyone came anything. You're saying you're insane. Everyone
else like you're not like the focus right now. It's the >> uh
the the thing with the docs was kind saying that she gave her
address to >> let go. Annie, what? I cannot force this
guy. I can't force him to talk. What do you want me to do exactly?
What can I do in my shoes to force Resi to talk to IO? Explain
how I go call in. I want to call in. Oh, I don't want to call
in. >> Uh, do we get anything else out of this? I go call
in at the end. >> Hey, um, I just wanted to say I'm a little
It's not your fault. I'm a little irritated that the clip started
in the middle of me yelling at Duck about their relationship
cuz now it looks like I was coming in talking about their relationship
when really I >> Yeah, she was not. She was She was responding
to Duckbringer saying that I was like all over the place. >> Came
into chat. I didn't know what the [__] you guys were
talking about. I just heard Duck say that uh that I have a crush
on Resi or something and I was like what the [__]
do I joined? Okay. And I was just trying to get her to leave
me alone. So that sucks now that he's that he just is able to
go run off with that narrative. But he picked a narrative either
way. >> Well well regardless what he says, right? I don't
watch the stream. Okay. To be fair to be fair, I really noticed
that I watched where the clip started where it was sent to me.
I really consider that. Um but to be fair, everyone else who's
watched this has seen it in its entirety. The full clip has been
posted on Twitter. Um and he's definitely going to see it and
he probably can't really go and hate that narrative. I know he's
probably going to watch this back. He's definitely going to watch
it back. So I wouldn't really be too concerned about that. I
think it's going to be a huge deal. But I apologize that I I
was watching it from where it started. Um >> no, I understand.
I just want to clarify, you know, OCD stuff, but I I appreciate
that. Um I know you you did there was nothing more that you could
really do here. Nothing was gonna change anything. So,
>> All right. Thanks.
>> Let's get the out of here. Let's check out the resi
stream and then that's it for the stream tonight, guys. Resi
did a 9minute intro into
announcement. We got an announcement, guys. Oh, hello.
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> All right, so um I want to say this. I don't have IO
docs information. We never got that far in terms ter terms of
our
Um, and I don't think we will because we're not friends any longer.
As I've stated before, I have no idea why Duck intimated that
she had it. As far as I am concerned and understand, I've spoken
with Duck and it was because Aiko insinuated
that she had that information and then Duck said something along
the lines of, "Well, you shouldn't have done that." Which is
just stupid and a part of the >> uh She also kind of went
like, "I'mma do you. I'mma dox you." >> issue. Uh me and
Dr. Psychotic.
there's that. Yeah, this activity is unacceptable. Anything else?
I will likely continue to talk to Duck because I do think that
she has a lot of trauma
the abuse she suffered from her ex.
And I'm going to try to find try to help her find a tells her
to not just ignore it and actually deal with it. Okay. Anything
else you guys want to call in? Not what happened at all. Okay.
Well, broke up with them anyways, so you know.
Yeah, that's anything else. If you want to call in, I'll give
you like five minutes. I hope you're okay. I'm not.
>> But I'm not doing a stream that said I came here to
literally just do this. Um,
it is
whatever it is, the show must go on. Not tonight. I'm going to
deal with my own [__] tonight. Um,
but I need to make this unequivocal to her and everybody else
that I find this behavior unacceptable.
I find the threats unacceptable. It's just that >> this
is like rough actually >> going forward
I've said.
>> dude, I try not to put my emotions on the stream. Okay.
No stream tonight, guys, is what I would say. Why? I don't know
why you go live. I am going to continue to not be interacting
with the people I've said I'm not going to be interacting with.
I meant it. >> It wasn't about Duck.
That does frustrate me a little bit, but we'll see tomorrow.
Um, I want to keep this short. So, yeah. >> Uh, let's see.
All right. Anybody in the join here? Does not look like it. Give
you guys like a minute. >> I think I don't really need
to watch. >> Yeah. Yeah. It's icon >> my interactable
or not interactable. Intractable. Not interactable. So, is she
single?
>> Dude, what? Why would you read that message? Why would
you read that message?
That's rough. Why would you do
>> So, is she single? Yes. Cyanide.
Yeah, that's the funniest joke ever. >> Okay. No, he turned
it. That wasn't so bad. He kind of turned it.
>> What's up, Char? >> Hello, princess. How are you?
How are you doing, Point? >> I am no longer interacting
with Shy Bunny online. I'm kidding, obviously. Um, yeah. Good
news is you don't have to go to Florida. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. So,
re-watch the stream if you want. I am not going to kind of go
through this any further. I'm not going to be involved in
being someone's partner as well as their counselor. Easy enough.
Good enough. >> Easy enough. Okay. All right. Take care.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
>> Bye-bye.
That's same. Same though. Same though. Take care, guys. And we
will see you all tomorrow. I'm going to send you over to I think
Perry's the only person who I like know is online. Yeah. Well,
Nacho Mama's online too, but I'm shooting people over to Perry.
Okay. Bye, Mal. Bye, Mal. See you later. Ler box and a boy exposed
the flaws in Pisco's Destiny debate. Okay.
I don't want to watch this loader box review of this debate.
I feel like I'd be pretty annoyed. We'll see. Okay. All right.
Um, send you guys over to Perry. Have a good one. Good night,
guys. Bye-bye.